this is Jocko podcast number 388 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening
General mukayama
told me that Colonel hackworth never did
things for personal gain
he always did things for the unit
and for the soldiers
Ford the soldiers
that is the underlying theme that
permeates about face and is the
underlying theme that stuck with me as a
leader
but people's strengths are often also
their weaknesses
and perhaps doing things for the
soldiers was Colonel hackworth's undoing
in his interview with issues and answers
when Howard Tucker asked him if he'd
become too emotionally involved in
Vietnam he responded
one couldn't have spent the number of
years I've spent in Vietnam without
becoming emotionally involved
one couldn't see the number of young
studs die or be terribly wounded without
becoming emotionally involved
I just have seen The American Nation
spend so much of its wonderful great
young men in this country
I've seen our national wealth being
drained away
I see the nation being split apart and
almost being ripped asunder because of
this war
and I am wondering to what end
it is all going to lead to
so that's the from the forward that I
wrote
for the book about faith by Colonel
David hackworth
and that idea
that he instilled in me of caring about
his soldiers caring about my people
first and foremost
that's what he's all about
he dedicated the book to all the Dough
Boys The Ground Pounders the grunts the
American infantrymen past present and
especially future
and I wrote in that forward
for about face that the lessons that he
learned
and passed on in his book
I had used in combat and I had passed
them on as well not only to the seals
replacing me but I passed them on to
Soldiers and Sailors and Airmen and
Marines at units throughout the country
and around the world
foreign
but his lessons went beyond that
I wrote about that in the forward I
continued by saying hackworth's
leadership philosophies strategies and
tactics can be applied by any leader at
any level in any situation
I have taught your principles to
countless civilian leaders in every
industry imaginable and have seen them
applied over and over again with
extraordinary outcomes
so the principles that I learned from
hackworth
and principles that I learned from my
seal forefathers and from other military
leaders and that are from the Army in
the Marine Corps and principles that I
learned from military history
all those lessons
they all originated in combat that's
where they're from
but we now know that they apply
everywhere
and we know that because we have seen
them applied in every Arena
and when we see them applied as I said
we see them applied
with extraordinary results and one
incredible example of that is actually
within one of my companies Echelon front
my leadership consultancy where one
person has applied the principles of
extreme ownership in everything that she
does
to take care of
her soldiers
which is actually her team in Echelon
front she uses the principles to pass on
incredible knowledge to clients
to run our business
which is the Premier leadership
consultancy in the world she uses them
to raise her family to run a household
to support her children to support her
husband
to take care of her friends
and to grow and create in short she uses
these principles
to lead
and she is the chief operating officer
at Echelon front her name is Jamie
Cochran and she's here with us tonight
to share her her perspective
and her Lessons Learned Jamie thanks for
joining us thank you for having me I had
to start with hackworth
because
you take the thread
the thread leads back to hackworth the
thread of my thoughts lead back to
hackworth and look there's there's a
other huge influences in there Delta
Charlie's in there he's in the threat
Roger Hayden's in the thread and there's
a bunch of people that obviously know I
can't recite them all
but that thread like I said all those
lessons originated in combat that's
where that's where they come from
and so to see what we've done for the
last 12 years and to see the way these
things are applied and to see the
results in every industry
Dairy Farmers
insurance companies
manufacturing companies software
companies Hardware companies financial
companies
just every industry energy construction
every industry and they put these things
to use
and it's been it's always cool to track
how they do but it's really kind of cool
to track you
and what you've done with these
principles and it's a really good
Testament to the way these principles
apply outside of the battlefield
so let's let's figure out how you got
here let's start at the beginning Jamie
Cochran uh where were you born I was
born in Utah Orem Utah but when I was
three I moved up to Washington State
just south of Seattle so that's really
what I call home
and what would your mom do
my mom we actually moved to Seattle for
my mom's job she worked for the United
Steel worker she worked there for 35
years she was dedicated yes she loved
loved loved helping people and she loved
her job she was talk about work ethic
what was her job in the Union
she was basically I mean back then they
called him secretary she was basically a
secretary but she ran that place uh for
sure and she later in her career you got
those jeans from her then huh 100 I
learned a lot from her
um and she later in her career there she
ended up taking on a program that they
had women in steel and she took that on
and started actually teaching and
training and setting up these programs
for women in steel helping them
understand that there was leadership
opportunities for them so I learned a
lot from her and then what about your
dad what was he doing Blue Collar uh he
worked at an aluminum aluminum plant so
he actually worked at a company in my
mom's Union served uh really harsh work
environment I worked a lot of graveyard
shifts and different kind of shift work
growing up so they were a big team
because my dad was you know working
different shifts my mom was traveling
for work and so they both work full time
and so they really had to work together
as a team my dad dabbled in some
construction ran his own business for a
little while and then ended up back at
like a plant a aluminum printing plant
and then what about brothers and sisters
what do you got I have one brother he's
nine years older than me uh we were very
close growing up given our age different
still very close now he was a wrestler
so all I wanted all I wanted to do when
I was little was just hang out with my
brother uh interesting you know we'd go
to wrestling tournaments I'd help roll
up the mats and then he'd come home and
you know wrestlers stink and he would go
sit in his room and I would just want to
sit next to him and hang out with him
and his buddies like I just really
idolized and looked out to him a lot but
girls weren't really wrestling no I mean
there was some but not like it is now
now there's no there's like girls
wrestling yeah oh I never saw it growing
up but I was there every weekend I was
watching him wrestle I mean he he
focused in on one thing different for me
very different for me in a lot of ways
but he focused in on one thing and he
put all of his time and effort in
wrestling and so I grew up around that
community
and then so what were you into since you
didn't have the wrestling Outlet which
now I'm like kind of bummed out I'm
bummed out in the world that you weren't
a freaking wrestler uh I would have
loved that we caught up too we'll get to
that later I was one of those kids that
I just needed to do a million things
when I was really little I started out
in gymnastics and I got very competitive
in gymnastics and it's where I put all
of my effort and energy but by the time
I got to middle school I just wanted to
try it all so I don't I don't know how
my parents kept up with me but I was in
every sport you can imagine I started
you know going into plays and singing
and just literally my schedule was
constantly packed I went from one sport
to the next to the next to the next all
through high school when did how old
were you started uh gymnastics I was
three okay what level did you make it to
uh a level ten but I wasn't happy no I
mean it's it's changed a lot so like
level 10 back when I was little is not
the level tens you see now the level
tens you see now are freaking beasts uh
I was not at that level but I was
competitive for for my age and I and I
continued gymnastics through High School
how many times a week or yeah how many
times a week did you have to train
gymnastics a lot isn't it like when you
get to level six or seven you're
training every day right yes I mean we
had sometimes four or five hour
practices on Saturdays I'm just training
you know we would do a round of a
workout and then we would go through our
routines and then we would go through a
round of stretching and then back to a
workout I mean it was pretty intense for
fifth grade to be that deep immersed in
in a sport and you loved it I loved it
and then I got to Junior High and I kind
of it wasn't that I didn't like
gymnastics anymore it wasn't burnt out
per se I just wanted to try new things
and you can't really do that if you're a
competitive in gymnastics so I had to
adjust a little bit and stop competing
competitively for the club that I was at
and start just doing that for school so
that I could do other sports did anyone
talk you through that or did you figure
that out I just figured that out my mom
and dad were so supportive they never
pushed me towards any of this so me
competing in gymnastics was not them
being like you have to do this and up
until that point they had spent so much
money and time in me doing this Sport
and they were always so supportive my
mom's one rule at least when we got
through high school but this we kind of
started this when I was little was that
you're not going to come home after
school and just have nothing to do they
both worked so I needed to have
something to keep my time so when I was
younger that was gymnastics and then as
I got older it was like you either get a
job or you're gonna play a sport but
you're not going to come home and just
have a bunch of extra time on your hands
so they they were good with it did you
have competitive gymnastics in your high
school we did yeah yeah that's pretty
lucky yeah yeah you must were you kind
of a Slayer because you were like a club
gymnast yeah we had a couple a couple
other club gymnasts so we had it just a
lot of fun we had this old German his
name was Gunter Borman uh gymnastics
coach he was super strict really tough
but he was so such a great just such a
great coach
um and I got to in my Junior and senior
take on the captain role and really
really fun opportunities in your Junior
and Senior year was that was that rare
for a junior to be Captain I mean
gymnastics teams are smaller so not so
much
um but we had a co-captain role when I
was a junior so there was a senior that
was in that place as well and then when
I was a senior I took on the captain
role again and then what and then what
else were you doing volleyball played
volleyball loved that Sport and I also
played softball
were you good at both those two I was
good at both those I I was I was never
the best there was always people on the
teams that I played at that were
significantly better than I was and put
a lot of their time and effort and
training but I played I started and I
played in both of those Sports
gymnastics is an awesome base sport
because you just get strong flexible you
proprioception is is outstanding the
discipline that it takes to do it like
that's a good sport to kick it off with
yeah I always tell you know my kids my
daughter didn't do gymnastics but she
did wrestling when she was little and I
think both of those sports are such good
introductory sports for kids because you
learn balance you learn strength and
it's it's kind of a gut check like
wrestling and gymnastics like those
practices are not easy you are going
hard and there's this level of
discipline you learn at such a young age
that there's really good base level
sports for for kids
one thing I don't know if gymnastics is
like this in wrestling You're Gonna Lose
you know what I mean like you're gonna
lose and I think that's also good for
kids to lose and have it be on you
because like you know your soccer team
loses you're kind of like well you know
Jamie missed the goal and it's kind of
her fault and Echo didn't do a good job
on defense but I did awesome you can
kind of Coach yourself through that
rationalize your but in wrestling is it
like that in gymnastics I mean it must
be similar it is because you compete by
yourself so you're out there by yourself
and so there's two scores you get your
individual score I was an all-around
gymnast so I did all four activities
um and so I had my own scores that I was
competing against others individually
but then all your scores also go to the
team score so similar to in wrestling
but you're out there by yourself so if
you mess up you're out there by yourself
you have to finish the routine even if
you know you've stepped out of line and
now you're you know there's no shot
you're going to get a good score on this
um so it was yeah I learned a lot and
people can have mental breakdowns with
that kind of thing too by the way I mean
like kids sports like step outside the
line everything falls apart you gotta
that's it's so good to go through that
stuff
um and then you mentioned singing the
obviously you've got some pipes on you
yeah I auditioned for a play in fifth
grade I never done anything like that
and I auditioned for a play it was a
play that our the direct the music
director there had written himself it
was called Journey To Echo Mountain and
I auditioned and I had no idea I've
never done anything like this and it was
a musical and I got the lead I got the
lead her name was Molly and I just kind
of immersed myself in this new world in
fifth grade of I'd never sang before I'd
never had any kind of lessons before and
now I'm you know in this play so what
happened with the journey to Echo
mountains what was the play about it was
a it was a girl who like didn't have any
friends and her it was like this fantasy
thing where like her favorite little
stuffed doll became real and she goes on
this journey with him to Echo Mountain
to save his friends it was a very
interesting play but it had all these
songs and so the first night the opening
night we were prepping in the morning
and I was like I was coughing and I was
having all these like issues and my mom
gave me old cough medicine she didn't
realize it was expired so now I'm
throwing up opening day first time I'm
ever going on stage and she takes me to
the hospital just in the morning because
I'm really sick I found out I have
asthma so I just in internally just
started to panic about this opening
night get the inhaler good to go rush
back go on stage and we ran I think
another six shows over the next two
weeks and I was in love I was like this
is so fun my oldest daughter
I remember she was Aunt she they did
Annie at the school play and she was
Annie
and her you know I was thinking it was
like you know you I was a little bit
detached I was in the Navy so I show up
whatever opening night and I and I'm
kind of thinking wow
this is a lot of pressure and she's in
fifth grade or sixth grade Maybe
and then she's got to get up on stage
and like sing and the whole no offense
to the other roles but basically when
you're when you're Annie and Annie that
whole freaking show rests on your
shoulders and she was 10 years old and I
was like man that's impressive that's an
impressive thing to be able to do that
and step out there and let it rip with
the pipes
uh and so then you kind of got into that
scene a little bit I did after that I
was like I love this performing is
awesome and so I joined the choir and I
did choir all throughout High School I
started taking vocal lessons I started
going to summer camps where we would go
for like a month and we would all the
whole summer camp was just for the sake
of putting on a show at the end of that
and we would do musicals and plays every
summer so in the midst of sports and
that's what I meant I went from one
thing to the next to the next I was also
really wrapped up in singing and
Performing and just wanting to get
better and find other ways to explore
the performance Zone where was this um
drive this is a lot you know I you see
kids that are sitting around watching
playing video games and there you are
doing Nine Sports Plus starring in the
musical in fifth grade where's that
coming from I don't know so part of it I
think was my parents there was kind of
two really big themes in my childhood
was work ethic so my parents always
drove home the importance of work ethic
you're going to show up on time you're
not going to miss anything and you're
going to do the job and you're going to
do it well and then honesty was another
big theme in my childhood so I had a
good example of watching them and then I
had my brother who really honed in on
one thing and loved that one thing and I
just realized I don't it wasn't anything
specific but I just realized at a
certain age it was probably around fifth
or sixth grade that I didn't want to
just do one thing I wanted to do it all
and I started to realize that I loved
the challenge I really thrived in like
the constant change and the constant
challenge of things going on so I just I
don't know I just wanted to be in
everything were you that self-aware in
sixth grade that you were like I really
enjoy this challenge
I think so I mean I I think I think I
might be an idiot you know what I mean I
think when I'm in fifth grade I'm like
throwing rocks at trees like that's
that's the extent of my forward thinking
I'm thinking hey I bet I can hit that
beehive with a rock and run away quick
enough do you think I can do it yeah I
think you can let's try but I think the
downside is there's a lot of people like
my brother that honed in and became
really great at one thing and I was on
College
um he did not he he did for like the
first year and then he didn't he didn't
finish college
um but he was a great wrestler and he
was really good at that Sport and he put
all of his energy and effort into it and
I was a little bit more like oh that
looks fun that looks fun let me try this
oh that looks cool let me do this and I
just always I couldn't keep my attention
I just wanted to do it all
um you know and that got me in trouble
sometimes for the most part I just loved
having the constant change going on in
my life and were you you know you were
the captain of this team you were the
captain of the team you're the lead in
this were you you always sort of did you
always kind of get elevated
to sort of leadership roles as you were
growing up I did I mean I did student
body government and things of that
nature I like I was I just talked a lot
if I'm being honest like so like people
knew me because I just talked to like I
always had Straight A's and then when it
got to the point of like talking in
class I'd always get the two like the
the lower rating because I just I was
just a chatterbox uh I would spend hours
in my room my mom has tapes of me doing
interviews with myself and playing
different characters like different
accents and I'm like and now welcome to
the show and I was like and I would just
spend all this time creating and talking
and so I think I just I was a little bit
of just I think I just was loud and so
people are like well okay let's just put
her somewhere just to manage that
and so as you're going through high
school you're doing all these activities
do you have do you start to see some
kind of a vision for what you want to do
with your life as far as career goes you
know not really I
all I knew in high school was that I
loved performing and I loved singing and
that I really just liked again kind of
the chaos of having a million things
going on and so all I ever thought I
wanted to be was I'm gonna move to LA
when I'm 18 and I'm gonna go and I'm
gonna sing I'm gonna sing and I'm gonna
write and I'm just that that was my path
uh in high school at least and then I
quickly quickly realized that that
wasn't actually what I wanted well so
okay so you have this dream you graduate
from high school
and then so do you go to college for
music right then you go to college for
singing yeah so none of my none of my
family had ever gone to college so going
to college was a big deal and my parents
always were like you're gonna go to
college like you're gonna do this and I
always wanted to go to school I knew
that I wanted to go to college but I
didn't really know where to go or like
what I wanted to do so I applied to a
bunch of different schools but my choir
teacher at the time who I really looked
up with and looked up to and had a
really good relationship she was the one
that was like I think you should look at
Azusa Pacific and it was a private
school but she knew the the music
director there and she's like I can get
you set up with an inner an audition and
you could maybe get some money to go to
school because we didn't my parents had
saved money but not enough to
necessarily send me to four years at a
private university
um so I went and auditioned and I ended
up getting a scholarship there so I got
into other colleges but because of the
scholarship I chose to go to Azusa
Pacific do you get to pick the song
you're going to sing for you on Dish yes
yeah I think they gave you I I couldn't
remember I mean it was probably more
classical because that's you know what
they expected going into like a music
program what kind of music were you
listening to in high school everything
so it was one thing that I I grew up
with my dad who loves music I mean he
had towers of just CDs back in the day
like you know just racks and racks and
CDs and he would listen to literally
everything I mean everything from like
country to Whitney Houston to rap to
like my dad had it all and so I got
exposure to everything but the one thing
that we really bonded over we still do
we share songs like I'll send him a song
he'll send me something to be heroes was
just music's music that had a story so I
always loved the singer-songwriter like
if there's a good story it didn't so
much matter about the rest if there was
a good if it made you feel something did
you ever pick up a gift box a guitar or
anything no I never did and I wish I had
but I think I was I was too busy so I
could only manage just singing and I was
lucky to have enough people around me
that could do the music part did you
ever get in any trouble in high school
before you get to College you know I
didn't that's what I was thinking you're
over there just being perfect yeah
I really didn't I I got good grades and
we had our school system had a very
interesting they had like these secret
high school students that would go to
parties and like basically rat out other
athletes yeah and it was all it was all
about the athletic clubs and making sure
that the athletes weren't going to these
parties so you had like a 20-minute
leeway and so I had that kind of keeping
me from getting into trouble and
honestly I probably would have gotten
into a lot of trouble except my best
friend was like an angel and perfect and
she you want to talk about leadership
she led me in high school and she's like
nope you're not doing that she was also
an athlete and so she was very much in
my corner and kept me from making lots
of bad decisions did you ever did you
ever figure out who one of the rats was
no
who takes that job on like that's risky
yeah that's a very strange thing so
you'd go you there was parties but you
kind of would show up and leave
basically I remember one time my my
parents dropped me off at this at this
house and you could tell like when they
dropped me off you could tell that this
was a party and my mom's like okay and
you you're you're gonna go to this and
just a lot of trust you know and but so
they were suspect and I was like yeah no
Mom it's totally fine like it's just
some friends getting together and like
you can see the house you're like this
is a raging party and I went in and I
spent like 15 minutes and I was like all
right I probably shouldn't be here it's
total Mayhem so I called her and I was
like hey Mom can you come get me and
she's like oh my gosh yes we're up the
street we'll be right there she like
waited up the road just hoping I'd make
the right decision so I was friends with
all the people that partied but I just
kind of stayed out of that for for the
most part I definitely went to some but
I do you think you're caught up do you
think you didn't want to let your
parents down do you think you didn't
want to let your team down like this is
kind of really positive peer pressure
because most kids are getting peer
pressure to do negative things what kind
of peer pressure was it just like hey I
want to let my parents down yep my
biggest fear growing up my absolute
biggest fear even if this day was
disappointing my mom and dad because
they were such pillars in my life and
like I just highly highly respected them
growing up that I just didn't want to
let them down like I was so afraid of
that so I made a lot of good choices
because I was like I don't have to show
up and be like hey Dad I screwed up
are you guys having dinner together
every night like but your dad's working
shifts like how is this really tight
family unit and this this high level of
respect for your parents how did they
how did they formulate that I think a
couple things one my parents are best
friends
and they are a true partnership They
Carried the load together and so
um they just they just work together so
well my mom would travel and my dad
would have to take on like feeding us
every night and yes we had dinner most
nights at the table and sometimes it was
in the midst of things but it was like
Hey at 6 30 be home we're gonna have
dinner at the table and my mom would go
out of town and my dad would do like
seven days of different ground beef like
we're having Hamburger Helper and then
spaghetti then sloppy joes then goulash
like variations of ground beef but my
dad in a while that was a big one at my
house
together bro but he would he would
manage food when my mom was gone and
when he worked shift work my mom was
there and I think what I'm very very
lucky is that I was a busy kid I had a
lot of stuff going on and yet I can't
remember a time and it had to have
happened that um but I can't remember a
time where I didn't have both parents or
at least one parent or in the very rare
occasion they both couldn't be there
they said my brother they're like you're
going to support so I always had someone
in the stand there rooting for me that
just wanted the best for me and I think
um that cultivated like a very we're
we're an oddly close family even now
into adulthood uh my my dad and my
brother are best friends and they do so
much together even now we're very very
close I think compared to a lot of other
families yeah that's I I've I talk about
the fact that I've told so many parents
like Hey listen your kids are gonna get
this rebellious streak they know they
got to leave the house they don't want
to do it when when they're so close to
you so they're gonna do some things to
create a little separation just expect
this but you didn't even have that no I
mean I hit my rebellious stage in in
college because I was I wasn't near them
anymore so I went through that whole
stage when I got to college and I was
living in LA and just trying to figure
out who I wanted to be what I wanted to
be
so you don't remember you're a dish song
but you knocked it out of the park you
get the big scholarship to a zoo what is
it Azusa Azusa Pacific Azusa Pacific
and now you're leaving your family did
your mom cry did you cry did your dad
cry was it total I'm just picturing like
just total mental breakdown in the fam
we drove from Seattle to California oh
they're driving you hell yeah they're
like we're driving again and I like
slept the whole time you know because
I'm young like whatever my they drove
the whole time they get me set up in my
apartment and my roommates in my first
year in this dorm we lived on campus it
was a small room three beds and like a
dresser tiny I mean probably the size of
this room and uh both of them were from
Okinawa Japan so there was just an
interesting Dynamic right out the gate
they helped me move in and they've got
to get back so we go to this parking lot
my dad gets my car off the back he had
it on a trailer and like
gave me a hug and drove off and I
remember sitting there in the parking
lot by myself like what have I done I am
now in Los Angeles by myself and my
parents just drove away and in the
moment we kept it kind of together but
my mom lost it in the car I lost it in
the car separate of each other uh just
feeling like what what have I done and
so now you got two roommates from
Okinawa
well that's kind of random were they
sisters or something they were they came
from the same high school okay
um but yes they were wonderful they were
wonderful roommates is that college
meant for like performance because
you're going there you're going there to
major in singing I went there and my
major was vocal performance so I was a
part of the women's choir which you have
to be your first year and then there's
opportunities to move into some of the
other uh choir units and I was taking
primarily music classes and I always
tell students now like just go do your
general education because you don't know
what you want to do and I made the
mistake of like some people go join the
Marine Corps and then you figure out
what you want to do perfect but a lot of
people make the mistake just like I did
where I went and I'm like okay I'm a
vocal performance major I'm gonna take
all music classes I'm just gonna get
deep into music composition and all
these different things and then about
six months in I realized I don't want to
do this anymore because I realized that
I loved singing but I didn't really
necessarily like like learning and the
components and the teaching and the
technical side of it and that I didn't
need any of that to go perform and sing
you just need that microphone yeah yep
so you're going through that decision
process again you're aware for a young
person even when I was thank God I was
in the Navy because God only knows what
I've been doing if I wasn't but you're
now 18 probably 19 years old you take
this all these music classes and you
realize you like singing but you don't
want to learn about sheet music or
whatever it is music theory
so then what do you do you decide you're
going to change Majors yep I decide I as
part of my General Ed I did take a
marketing class and I was I loved that
class and it started to open my eyes to
like oh okay you know what maybe there's
something I kind of like event planning
I like marketing I like this other world
I also started to realize that uh I was
not even with my scholarship I was not
going to be able to afford to stay at
Azusa Pacific because we had basically
depleted my college saving funds to go
to that first year was not a cheap
school and so I was realizing that I was
gonna have to go in significant debt it
to stay there so I was like all right
I'm changing Majors I'm gonna move
school so I moved after the first year
and I started summer school classes to
try to catch up because I've now changed
Majors uh right after I left Azusa and I
went to Cal State Los Angeles and I
changed to Communications and public
relations what's where's Cal State Los
Angeles kind of East L.A um not far from
like Pasadena okay about 15 minutes like
east of that and so do you move in an
apartment with new people obviously yeah
so really kind of crazy twist of fate I
showed up and the apartment the dorm
that I was supposed to stay in was a
four bedroom dorm so eight girls and
like this common space and all seven of
the eight so the other seven were on the
soccer team together and then me so I
show up and I go to to move in and
they've moved me to a different room so
I went back just to get a new key and I
didn't I didn't want to cause drama I
was like no I just need a new key so I
can get into this new room that they've
shifted me and it created this whole
Whirlwind and she ended up saying no I'm
gonna move you to this other apartment
with one of our resident assistants and
so I moved in uh with this girl named
Diana who ended up becoming my best
friend but she didn't she didn't want me
moving in with her
um but all of a sudden I'm in I'm now
it's just three girls in a two bedroom
and it turned out to be a cool twist of
fate because it led me to a job where I
worked at the college as a resident
assistant like the next quarter
um and just cultivated some friendships
I wouldn't have had if I had been in the
soccer house the soccer house so you get
moved into this new place and now you're
studying Communications and public
relations
what is what is what does it mean when
you study Communications
you don't know
I don't know what what who
what job do you get hired into if you
study Communications you get like I mean
are you a newscaster are you uh writing
take the journalism route I took the
public relations route so really you
know uh it was a component of marketing
but not the marketing degree
um it was a little bit more towards you
know learning how to communicate how to
tell a story how to you know I could
have gone and worked at like a PR firm
what I loved at the time is I was a
resident assistant and so what I was
doing on campus in addition to just the
regular duties there was I was planning
events and there's a component of the
communications degree that sets you up
for that because you have to Market and
publicize these events and there it just
gave me some exposure I I didn't know
what I wanted to be so I kind of landed
there haphazardly and it's stuck and I
really loved Cal State because the
classes were smaller so I got to know my
teachers more and I just started to
cultivate relationships there that I
hadn't a year prior and you're out of
money kind of so you got to be working
oh I was broke I was so broke I remember
are pulling into a gas station trying to
get back to campus and like going up to
the counter and being like I have three
dollars and 23 cents on before you know
my parents made sure that I had food so
I had the campus meal plan and I had
housing and everything else was up to me
um and so I ended up getting a job
initially at a restaurant and I started
as a Hostess and then worked my way up
to various positions there and I worked
there all through college at a
restaurant McCormick and Schmick's what
kind of restaurant is that like a fish
house yeah like a seafood they had yeah
and did you end up as a waitress what'd
you learn from that
a lot because I started as a Hostess and
then I became a waitress then the
cocktail waitress so I worked in like
the happy hour so you just get to meet
all sorts of different people uh not
only the people that you work with but
the people you're meeting on a day to
day you have to manage emotions if
something if an order gets wrong people
treat people in the service industry
terribly others treated me great but I
had to learn a lot how to like control
my emotions and like show up on time and
it was it was a great job I loved it I
was there for a long time and I had a
couple key relationships there that were
really important to me in my development
as far as like being mentors
so you end up how much you make a night
as a waitress
uh
I think I would I mean sometimes I'd
walk out of there with some pretty good
cash if it was a busy night because I
would work happy hour I would take extra
shifts
um maybe a couple hundred bucks yeah
yeah some people become kind of career
waitresses sometimes because you can
make good money well this was before
like people were doing the the
guaranteed 20 like nowadays I feel like
it's on everything you know they didn't
have the little key at the bottom that
suggested the amount so sometimes you'd
get totally stiffed and other times you
know people were really generous but I
relied heavily on the cash tips that was
a big part of my income and then you
also were working as an RA is that right
yep so are you dealing with freaking
just Mayhem Mayhem just people puking on
themselves just drinking yeah drugs it
was an interesting leadership lesson
because it was they weren't dorms it was
Apartments so it was almost like just
managing apartment complex but quarterly
we had to do like review we had to go
and like evaluate and do walk-throughs
and it was my job to like go in and see
if how they're living and whether or not
they're violating their rules if I was
on duty then I'd have to go let people
in in the middle of the night you you
were on duty for like three or four days
like around the clock so they people
would call you at 2AM and be like I
locked myself out and you have to go get
them situated so it was a lot of like
management and it's your peers too so
parties are happening and you've got to
go like kind of shut them down or noise
complains totally
I was a pretty cool rat but yes I had to
go shut some of those things down
um and then in addition to that it was
our job to put on events every every
couple weeks we do these different
events um what kind of events we one of
my favorite events there we started with
another friend of mine who was another
R.A and we called it the underground and
it was like a show of like poetry and
music and like dance and it was just
like this cool we turned this common
area that was you know you can think
like fluorescent lights kind of whatever
we turned it in this like cool dark
underground like club and we just had
different performances and artists come
and perform
did you perform yes singing I sang yeah
were you in a band I did have a band and
what was the name of the band uh it was
just me JJ Smith oh because your maiden
name is Smith yeah but you can't play
any instruments no but that was like
just acapella we just no no I had a band
we had a stand-up base we had a
guitarist a a drummer we had backup
singers
no my own stuff
where is it where's the mp3s let's go
that was a long time ago uh no we did I
mean we we had some covers but for the
most part we were writing our own music
and we would just we would link up on on
campus and we would just jam and then
over time we were like we should do a
show and so we went and played a little
show and then we we did a couple cool
gigs it was fun but did you do any
recording not with that band we didn't
record any of that stuff I was also
going to a studio in
um Hollywood and doing some like uh
vocal demoing so I would help write a
song or I would potentially or they
would give me a song that was written in
and I would demo it so that artists like
the the people that I was working for oh
just like a music company of some kind
yeah so I got I had a couple friends
that were in that and so I would go in
the studio and I would record a song
that they were going to send off to a
real artist who was already famous to
hear what the song would sound like so I
would demo the song
um and then on some cases I was asked to
do like little courses or things on on
people's others so I was recording but
not for my own stuff not my own songs
are you getting paid
not for that no you're just doing it for
free just doing it because we hear your
backing vocals on anything on the MP3
right now not that's like out I mean I
have them but no you're not on the
backing vocals of some band that we
could listen to I don't think so I mean
possibly I mean I did a lot of like
stuff but this was all like local stuff
going on it wasn't like you know some
big hit song have you sang any Jangles
that are commercials that we've heard no
you know like Geico or something they're
getting it that would have been where
the money's out though yeah
so all right so this is what you're
doing this was your rebellious phase was
you were like starting the underground
as an R.A no I'm just saying
I'm just saying
I'm fun in college and and maybe
realized uh was maybe happy when I met
my husband and he didn't drink to kind
of like shift because it wasn't ever
natural to who I was but it's hard to be
in L.A in that culture and not get
caught up in some of just the chaos and
drama of that culture
it's not a it's not a great place for
young women and I realized no not
College the music industry like I was I
wasn't I had enough of a foot in that
world that I really quickly realized
like I don't think that's the path I
want to go down it's kind of crazy it is
crazy
so
you're in college you get you go there
for three more years do you get it done
in four years I did yeah I went through
I did summer school every summer to make
up for the year of vocal performance
classes I took and I graduated on time
and then what's next what happens
I now 2006. yeah you graduate from
college yeah okay and my best friend we
ended up getting an apartment in
Pasadena and a one bedroom that we
shared and she was like hey I had this
idea she went to school for uh she had
her Master's in education brilliant and
um she was like I had this idea let's go
be flight attendants so we can just
travel the world and like just be single
and I was like awesome so we I was like
we're gonna do that that's the plan I
like the plan has two sentences we're
gonna travel the world and be single
okay we were both single at that time
and we were like all right we're just
gonna go do this and so we went it's
actually really hard to become a flight
attendant like people underestimate that
not only like the interviewing process
but then the training is significant
um and so we ended up becoming you know
getting the opportunity to go to this
training and in between when we got the
hey you know you're hired and the start
of training
I went on the first date now with Flynn
who is now my husband and so all of a
sudden like this whole I'm going to be
single kind of took a little pivot
um and she found out like right before
we went that she was pregnant so like
all of a sudden this travel the world
we're gonna be single and just living up
our life like both of us made this big
shift of like okay I guess things are
gonna change
um but I went through the training and
became a flight attendant and how long
did you do that for six six months I the
training is about eight weeks and then
uh which is it's sick it's difficult
training like people really don't get it
like when you go when you go on your
next flight treat those flight
attendants with care because they are
the parameters in which they have to
operate on that is so strict and so when
they're asking you to put your seat up
or your tray table there's reasons and
safety protocols for why and they've
trained to know every piece of the plane
for every plane that they could possibly
fly
um so it's just an interesting Dynamic
and when you hold on there's a reason I
gotta put my seat up when we're Landing
yes can you tell me what that reason is
yeah so it's like a two inch situation I
know but the research shows takeoff and
Landing is the most dangerous time on a
plane it's it's when you're most likely
to crash and if you do crash what
they're trying to do why you have to put
your seats under and your tray tables up
is create enough uh leeways so that if
you had to get out and evacuate you
could do that safely without things
being in the way and causing trip
hazards I always do it I kind of like
you know you talk about waitresses and
waiters and flight attendants like I
always think they've got like they're
having a bad day that's the way it
always seems to me because I know I
wouldn't you know I've worked in
restaurants and it's it's a hard job
I've never been a flight attendant but I
can just you know you just need to watch
one person be a jerk to a flight
attendant and you're like dude just
leave this person alone please they get
out of control so I always try and be
cool but I've always wondered why this
seat needs to be up
two inches like okay but now we know I
knew it was for that safety protocol but
still
um okay so you're doing that so I become
a flight attendant uh but by the time I
became a flight attendant you have when
you're first you know start off you are
at the bottom of the totem pole you have
no seniority and so you basically are on
call for several days you don't know
where you're going how long you're going
what you're doing you don't even know
what I mean I'm based out of LA but
there's three different airports we
serve four and so you could just get
called to say hey we need to do in
Burbank in three hours um and so forth
and at this time I'm kind of living in
San Diego because we made this one
bedroom apartment the crash pad for
eight other flight attendants so you you
walked into an apartment and there was
just mattresses and all eight flight
attendants because we couldn't afford
this rent anymore uh paid in to help
cover this rent so I had the option that
Fred gets an F for Planet I was stoked
on the two sentence plan I revoked that
I had like in my mind I'm like I would I
had the option of either going back to
the crash pad or driving two hours back
to San Diego so that's what I did I just
every time I finished even if it was a
16 20 hour day I would take a nap in my
car or go shower at the 24 Hour Fitness
and then drive back to San Diego
okay and then you're now you're you got
Flynn and Flynn's in the Navy at this
point yes he was in butts so we got
married
uh no actually yes he was I was a flight
attendant after we got married the the
whole time we were engaged I was a
flight attendant and he was just in the
in the regular Navy okay and then but
you know he's going to buds you find out
he's going to buds well yes when he
first asked me to marry him he you know
it proposed a river in the car
um
[Music]
it was basically like 10 out of ten yeah
yeah it was basically hey I'm supposed
to go to Japan in March and I'd like you
to come with me and I was like okay well
what does that mean he's like well you
can't really come with me unless we're
married and I was like so are you asking
me to marry you he's taking me in direct
approach yeah and he's like yeah pretty
much and he made up for it later he did
a whole thing but that's basically when
I agreed to marry him and at that point
he had orders to go to Japan where he
was going to be deployed for two years
and that was going to be his last
deployment he was going to get out
meanwhile unbeknownst to me he had
submitted a package to buds he was a
little old he was kind of on that cusp
um and so I don't think he told me
because he just wasn't sure if he'd get
in or not but he had submitted the
package to Buds and was waiting to hear
and then he found out
so he found out about a month before we
actually got married and what's going on
with the flight attendant yeah so I was
just you know just running up to La
every couple weeks or every couple days
um and flying
um and I ended up so I I really did love
that job but it was difficult it was
very difficult especially kind of
commuting back and forth which I made it
harder on myself because I did that
um and there was just a lot of lessons I
had some crazy stuff happen on planes
and uh I had just gotten to the point
where I don't know that I was fully into
it like I was already seeing like
there's there's an end here
um and I ended up I ended up like
shortly after we got married I got fired
I got fired how come you got fired well
they have really strict policy on
attendance and tardiness like you you
three strikes you're out and I could
give you all the explanations or reasons
why I was late three times I was
basically late for three times the
planes went off in time it was no big
issue but
um two times I was late one time I
called out and I could tell you in
detail why and all of that might make a
ton of sense but the reality was I did
not have any relationships there I did
not know my supervisor I didn't couldn't
even tell you his or her name
um it's not an office where you go into
so if you want to get to know your
supervisor you've got to like make an
appointment and plan to go to the
airport at some point and meet with them
and I didn't have those relationships so
despite the fact that I was a good
flight attendant and I got really good
ratings like customer ratings and I had
dealt with several major emergencies
very well
um despite that fact I just hit the
three strikes and I could give you all
the reasons and explanations but they're
just excuses and the reality is I had no
one to really call when it got to that
point and if I'm being honest at that
point I was kind of like it's okay I'm
kind of ready for something because
you're already married at this point
yeah okay so now you get married and is
that when Flynn starts buds yeah we got
married Friday afternoon uh evening uh
we went down to Arizona for a couple
days uh Scott's uh no I don't know not
Scottsdale Sedona yeah Sedona for two
days and then came back and he started
buds on Monday
and how was that
um just a really quick and Rapid
introduction to the Navy what did you
know anything about the Navy nope
I mean my parents have a lot of
um you know gratitude for our military
members I grew up in a house that really
valued our military members but all I
knew about the military I didn't know
anyone personally who served all I knew
about it was like what I learned in
history and what I saw on TV did you
know what a seal was no did you know
what buds was obviously didn't nope
okay so he starts Buds and so now are
you are you fired at this point I
continued as a flight attendant for like
another two months but it was shortly
after yes and then you guys are living
here in San Diego yeah and he's going
through buds what does it look like when
what does it look like from the outside
when your spouse is going through buds
yeah just basic skill training if you
don't and we were the only ones married
I don't think anyone else was married at
that time so that was a little bit of
like a unique scenario anyways but I had
like I had this vision of like what it
was going to be to be like newlyweds and
I'm young like I was I was 22.
I turned 23 like a week after we got
married so I was young and I was like oh
we're gonna like travel and we're gonna
hang out on the weekends we're gonna go
down the beach we lived a block from the
beach like a block from the hotel Dell
and I was like we're gonna spend all
this time doing all these fun things and
meeting new people and very quickly I
realized we're not doing any of that
that uh yeah I was lucky if he came home
he wasn't supposed to come home but we
were so close to the base that he came
home most nights even though he was
supposed to stay on base I think I can
say that he's he's long out I don't I
don't know I think you actually could go
home it's just that at the there's
probably some nights he wasn't supposed
to but but the officers pretty much were
allowed to go home and even married guys
were allowed to go home so it was
probably
what what what makes it
not smart is
you know you get done at midnight and
you've got to be back there at four
o'clock in the morning and so it's going
to take you 15 minutes to get off base
you know 10 minutes to get home park the
car get upstairs you just cost yourself
40 minutes there and then yeah you got
to get up earlier you got to make sure
you're gonna be on time so you got to
leave extra early so instead of sleeping
four hours you're sleeping three hours
and so that's probably where it seemed
like he shouldn't be coming home and he
was probably like I shouldn't be coming
home and he probably should have been
coming home but he did well I remember
one morning he woke up in a panic
because Brendan his his best friend
going through buds called him and was
like hey they just like pulled us out
get here now and so he like threw his
stuff on and he rushed out and he was
the OIC and so like he was supposed to
be there and he like rolled in and act
like he was like outside on a phone call
and like totally came under the radar
and like they didn't know that he was
not on base but he was supposed to be
there so there might have been times
where he was supposed to and he's still
kind of
um but it was interesting he would come
home and like just sand in the bed
constantly like he would wake up and
like like startle me like just you know
whatever it was he was sleep deprived
and he would wake up like in these like
massive uh like fits
um it just was interesting and then the
weekends like we weren't doing any of
the stuff I thought we were doing it was
definitely not like let's go to the
beach yeah no let's go swimming he don't
he wanted nothing to do with getting wet
and Sandy so we weren't going to the
beach
um and we ended up spending most of our
Saturdays in the first couple months
painting helmets at his like buddy's
house just me and like these three other
guys going through buds painting helmets
all day and that's that's where you met
Brendan yeah yeah Brendan was living
with a guy named Rob and that we would
just go to Brendan's house and barbecue
and paint helmets good times this is
exactly what you signed up for at 23
years old yep I was on stencil Duty I
was very good with the little details
yeah
so that's where you're starting to
understand what's happening and then was
there any highlights that you remember
what was what about hell week how was he
after hell week it was great um so
Brendan's mom had flown in town and she
we like spent a day or two together
before uh hell week was over just kind
of waiting for them to call and say I
made it and you start to feel pretty
good after Wednesday because I kept
thinking like what if he comes home
Tuesday like how do I respond and then
Wednesday yeah yeah I'm out
um Wednesday passed and we got into like
midday Thursday and I was like okay I
feel pretty good about this but you're
I'm nervous for him and Brendan's mom
was there so we ended up just kind of
hanging out in Coronado and then Friday
I don't remember what time it was but at
some point he called and he was like I
made it
um and he was like I just remember he
was like hey can you bring us milk
milkshakes and he was delirious and he
sounded like a like seven-year-old like
can you just please bring us milkshakes
I was like sure so Brendan's mom and I
went and gotten these chocolate
milkshakes and we went to base and we
sat in the back of his truck and it's
Rob Brendan and uh and Flynn and then
Brennan's mom and me and we're talking
and one guy would be talking and the
other two would be falling asleep and
then the other one would wake up and say
something and then the other guy would
start to fall asleep
um and very quickly you realize like man
they have been through something crazy
because Brent I mean Brennan couldn't
walk he had rashes everywhere
um and it just like you you saw it like
firsthand it was like this is crazy and
then obviously they have to leave and I
don't get to see him again for like 24
hours until they're medically cleared
but we did drop off those chocolate
milkshakes and they were stoked yes uh
and then what about the rest of buds was
there any issues did he did he get
rolled back or anything no nope he did
good he made it through all of that on
on track
um he obviously you know he was an
officer so we had to go through the
extra training so we ended up going to a
different class than when he went
through buds with
um but no uh
everything ran smoothly and then he gets
done with Buds and and he gets orders
where's he got team one team one yeah
and and now do you know what's going on
like
all I know is that he would be gone for
three weeks home for two days gone for a
week home for two weeks you know and
like we obviously talked about what he
was doing but I remember at one point I
was like hey do me a favor don't tell me
you're leaving until like two days
before because it would always be this
game of like hey I'm leaving in a week
and then he'd come home the next day
he's like actually we're leaving
tomorrow or I'm leaving in three days
actually it's two weeks and it was
always changing and I was like okay I'm
trying to handle like all this other
stuff I have going on in the midst of
like when are you going what are you
doing where are you coming when are you
gonna be home and so I was like just
tell me two days before you have to
leave and then tell me like the day
before you're coming back and then that
was just our our deal and so what are
you doing at this point
so after after I got fired uh I ended up
getting a job at a hedge fund
um and they were in downtown San Diego
and they worked off New York hours so I
had to be there at five and they were
done at three which was awesome in San
Diego because then I had all afternoon I
mean he wasn't coming home till late
anyways
um just to myself and kind of do
whatever I wanted in San Diego and I was
just basically an overpaid
Administrative Assistant for them
um uh so I I liked that job but it was
not very fulfilling was not challenging
at all and so before I had taken that
job there was this position that came up
at San Diego State University that
really piqued my interest but I looked
at the job description I'm like I
wouldn't qualify for this like what they
wanted I didn't have and so I didn't
apply and I took this job instead and
then a year after I served at the hedge
fund they moved back to New York and I
obviously wasn't going to go with them
so I started looking again and lo and
behold that position at San Diego State
had come up again which I guess could
would have been a red flag that like
someone didn't make it after a year but
whatever it was I thought you know what
there's no better time than at least
trying
so I applied for a job at San Diego
State and then you got the job
I did yeah uh to my utter surprise how
come you're so surprised because the
requirements of what they wanted they
prefer to master as they wanted several
years of experience I just didn't think
that I
qualified and I submitted my application
I ended up getting a screening call with
their HR director and I got off the call
and I was like Flynn there's no way
they're gonna hire me and then I got a
call and they're like hey we want you to
come in for a panel interview which I
had never done a group of like nine
people sitting around the table all from
various uh Parts on campus asking me
like intricate scenario based questions
and I'm just sitting there you know
going through this and I left that
interview and I was like Flynn they're
snowing they're going to hire me and
then two days later I got a call and I
had an interview with who the the woman
that ended up becoming my um was going
to be my direct supervisor if I got the
job and I got off that call and said
there's no way they're gonna hire me and
like a week later they offered me the
position and this whole time I was
pregnant and hiding it because I was
afraid that that would
impact my my uh
potential
okay yeah so your integrity just took a
hit yeah yeah yeah
I did tell her I told her in the final
interview I was like Hey I just have to
come clean
but yeah I was three months pregnant
with my oldest okay and so now what's
going on Flynn's now in a workup at a
team getting ready to go on deployment
and that's probably when I met him for
the first time putting him through those
workups when I was working at Trader
matter of fact that is when I met him
for the first time he still has notes in
his notebook says jko brief the Jocko
brief and it's the laws of combat which
is awesome that's rad uh
so now you you take this position what
are you doing in this new position that
you're at at San Diego State I was a
programs coordinator so I was
responsible for all of the programming
on campus so the associated students at
SDSU is a massive like it's 20 million
dollar Corporation essentially they run
and operate seven of the facilities on
campus and when I came into the job they
had just passed the year before a fee
referendum for the students where they
agreed to give more money to increase
the uh funds for the case which is the
program that I ran the cultural arts and
special events program uh with the
intent of you need to offer more
programming on campus and we want you to
do this Spring Festival it has to be a
sustainability Focus but we want it to
rival like USD Sun God and so I came
into a position where all of a sudden I
had to hire someone full-time that had
never been in a position a full-time
Assistant two graduate assistants
multiple part-time assistants student
assistants and advise the the student
Board of 60 students and it was and an
influx of cash an influx of money with
the intent of putting on this big
program so I came in like hot with all
these different things to do and I just
loved it I loved it it's not like you
like Mayhem I do a little bit yes well
so I went to USD yeah I don't remember
no Sun God yeah yeah everything going on
because I was a grown man what did you
guys do to rival Sun God yeah you know
that's a hard one because it's like a
long-standing history and ours had to be
sustainability focused so the first year
we run this event we called it grain
Fest and it was all sustainability
focused it was a week of events leading
up to this Festival concert and so the
first year we did it we did it out just
on a walkway we had like slightly stupid
we did this outdoor stage yeah
slightly stupid it was great for my
people there it was a phenomenal concert
but we had like 1500 students come to
that and everyone's like this is awesome
and I'm like we have 40 000 students
that this campus like 1500 is Lane so
the next year we brought out LMFAO and
we did it at the open air theater and we
had like 35 4 000 students and
everyone's like high-fiving like this is
great this is awesome and I'm like this
is weak so the next year we did it at
the Viejas Arena we sold out the arena
but before the concert we had this big
festival with rides and a beer garden
and there was all solar powered and all
this stuff
so then we had uh 9 500 students around
10 000 students and we sold that out and
everyone and now I'm like okay now we're
getting somewhere
um and then the last year before I left
we moved it with T-Pain we had three
music stages we had two a main stage a
side stage and then a DJ dance tent uh
all rides we shut down three big parking
lots and we had around 12 000 students
and it was just kind of continued growth
and at some juncture along the way you
had your first kid yeah in the like six
months after I got that job I hired a
full-time assistant and she had to
become the interim coordinator well I
took maternity leave and I took I worked
up until like a week before I had my son
and I came back like the second I could
I loved my child don't get me wrong but
I was like ready to get back and the
timing worked out really good because I
ended up having him in November and then
I was back right before our first green
Fest so all the work that we had done I
got to come and actually see it come to
fruition so how many how how long do you
get for maternity leave I took I took
exactly three months that's that's the
authorization yeah or whatever yeah so
you you have this first kid meanwhile
Flynn's just going on deployment he's
just gone all the time yeah when you
first check into a team you're just gone
yep you're just there's no there's
nothing yep
um seems like there's enough time to get
pregnant again though well he came back
yeah he came back and he's like I'm
ready to have a second child and like I
feel like I feel like the universe just
does whatever like Flynn puts it out in
the universe and the universe just
provides and so he gets back
um and I'm like no I am finally like in
this great state my job's going good
I've got this kid now he's two
um like one and a half and and I had
like finally lost all the weight I was
feeling good I was strong like I just
was so excited to just be that for like
the three months he was going to be home
and I finally convinced him like because
we're going back and forth and he's just
like I really think we should and I'm
like no I'm we're not
um and the whole time I'm arguing with
him I'm pregnant with our second son so
the universe provided and now uh yes I'm
pregnant with our second
all right so now that that takes place
you're you're pregnant again you're
still working the same job
um
then so this is now 2010 right yes Yep
this is this is when um
this is when Brendan died yep what what
did that look like from your perspective
so Brendan Looney just uh freaking
outstanding guy
um Titan helicopter in in Afghanistan
how did you and this is one of Flynn's
best friends yep
how did you hear about it
I was in my office at San Diego State
and I had a couple students and some
staff in there and we were having this
meeting and I had a big glass window or
like door and I remember seeing Flynn up
at the door and his eyes weren't red he
wasn't crying but I could immediately
tell something was wrong for him to come
into the office yeah very abnormal so I
was like why is he here and I could just
see it on his face
so I excused myself when I walked
outside and I thought like did something
happen to his dad like what what's going
on here and it took him a second and
then he told me about the helicopter
crash so he had heard about the crash
um and he talks about it as like knowing
like knowing Brandon was on that
helicopter and not being able to explain
why
um obviously not wanting that to be the
case but he basically went into Leaf's
uh office he worked with Leif at that
time at Seal Team One and basically went
in and just was like tell me it wasn't
Brennan and life wasn't able to give him
information initially because they
hadn't contacted Amy yet they were
trying to find her his wife
um and so Flynn kind of demanded again
like tell me it wasn't Brendan and he
could see it on leif's face
um and uh Leif was like hey we haven't
been able to contact Amy there's nothing
you can do right now but I'll call you
as soon as we find her so you can go to
the house
um
so he told me what had happened and
we didn't know what to do we were just
waiting to try to figure out how to help
um so we left and we got lunch we're
just waiting for this phone call and we
I remember we went to In and Out he
finished his meal and he goes okay
I'm done feeling sorry for myself let's
figure out what we can do for the family
and he just made this shift of like okay
we're just gonna figure out what's next
who would you part of the notification
for for Amy no so Amy was on a sales
call
um she was in a sales position and so
she was out on this call and nobody
could find her and so at this point they
were like hey sit tight and we'll call
you as soon as we find her because we
didn't know where she was
um and we got the phone call right after
he had kind of made that declaration
that like Hey we're not going to feel
sorry for ourselves we're gonna go just
figure out how to help
um and we got the call that they had
found Amy and that we could now go to
the house so we went to Amy's house
um about a half an hour after she had
been delivered the news
when you were at that time you know you
got Flynn kind of going on deployment
and it's sort of
you know you where were you guys living
Claremont Mesa so you're living in
Claremont Mesa you know you're working
he's disappears but you don't really
think about where he's at like it seems
like it's very easy living in San Diego
California that the war isn't a real
thing 100 I thought my husband and his
teammates were invincible
Invincible I was completely naive to
the reality that they may not come home
so when we found out about Brennan it
was devastating and devastating because
it like shattered this really cool Veil
I had as to what was going on and now
um you know I realized they're not
invincible and it was Brendan like one
of the best human beings one of the best
guys I've ever known and it just seemed
so unreal
you know I I always felt like when the
families would go to funerals like I I
can't tell what they're thinking but
you've got to imagine that every single
wife parent
son daughter is all thinking this could
be my dad this could be my husband this
could be my son like that has to be the
thought going through and that's why
those you know like um you know when I
had guys killed
I remember my wife going to these
services and I was like oh my gosh this
is gonna be
just such a shock to the system and you
know what's interesting is I went I have
like emails
that I'd be sending my wife and my wife
you know we're in the middle of the
battle of ramadi guys are getting Army
and Marine Corps guys are getting
wounded and killed every day and I'm
sending my wife emails like oh hey you
know how's like literally not one
indication of any kind at all that
there's a war going on that there's any
danger of any kind uh Mikey Monsour same
thing you know talk to to his family and
they're like yeah he Mikey monster who
is in a gun fight on a daily basic basis
practically the entire deployment was
like they're like oh what are you doing
over there and he says oh you know we're
just training Iraqis we don't do very
much it's boring he's telling his family
it's boring
so that it's I I think it's just to to
to recognize the fact that
especially I think in San Diego you know
if you're in if you're at Fort Campbell
Kentucky like the whole the whole it's
such a focus and and the the Airborne
divisions are huge and everybody's a
part of it in San Diego you know you're
in the SEAL Teams like you're you not
everyone's a part of it and there's a
bunch of Navy people but they're not
gonna be getting killed in combat and so
you get very very detached from or like
you said like there's a there's a
protective screen up that you don't
realize when these guys get on a plane
they might not come back and
um yeah I I can't imagine how that
impacted
you your thoughts your family
um as that happened and as you watch
this happen to to Amy
I figured out really early because we
got to this house and I'm pregnant at
this time too so I've just got a bunch
of you know heightened emotions anyways
and I walked into that room and I just
remember thinking like I can't do this
like she had a really good friend and
her sister-in-law that was there and
they were sitting on the couch holding
her hand and I had a moment where I
could give her a hug and kind of hold
her hand and then very quickly I was
like I don't have the capacity to do
this and so I went over to the caico
officer and I was like hey what can I do
to help can you just give me something
to do and he was like yeah actually I
need someone to go in the office and
find something he was looking for some
paperwork and so that's really how I
manage that entire uh
Excursion is the is looking for things
to do even when we ended up going out to
the family in the funeral it was like
cool I'll make the programs I'll go meet
with the people at the church with the
family I'll order dinner like just give
me something to do because I can't
emotionally handle the weight of this
right now it was too much at a young age
to to manage and I couldn't I can't even
fathom if I was feeling that the way
that that Amy was feeling yeah very
similar to my sort of standard operating
procedure in those times it was like
okay I need to do work I need to find
something to do and that's I don't think
a bad thing you know it might not be the
healthiest thing in the world but I'll
tell you what you got to get through
especially when there's the family and
you know like you gotta support them
that's got to become the focus not your
own personal grief for sure and you know
and Amy
ended up with Ryan and and Heather Kelly
writing the book um a knock at the door
actually covered it with Ryan on this
podcast podcast 201 just a very powerful
book and incredible to hear their
perspective
through these terrible terrible
situations
[Music]
it
you now have a son yep named Brendan yep
so Brendan Brennan passed in September
2010 and my second we didn't know if it
was a boy or girl and we were at his
funeral
um and we got in the car and Flynn kind
of lost it and then when he kind of
compiled himself he was like I just have
this Instinct that it's a boy that our
child is a boy and I want to name him
Brendan and I want to ask the family and
he was asking for my permission I was
like yeah go for it and so he talked to
the family shortly after that and asked
if that would be okay and Brennan my
Brendan was born in January and it was a
boy and we named him Brendan in in honor
of Brendan Looney
absolutely outstanding
was was Flynn did Flynn have another
deployment to do at this point yes yep
he he my son Brennan was born he was
home for like three days and then he
left but that was a training Excursion
and then I think it was like no uh yeah
it was a year later he did another
deployment to the Philippines this time
so you were a little bit more
comfortable when he's down there in the
Philippines as opposed to being over in
the Middle East at the time yeah he had
done an appointment to Yemen which was
definitely a little more heightened you
know because at the time there was a lot
of stuff going on the news about Yemen
and some of the the dangers there and I
didn't get to talk to him very much when
he was in Yemen hardly at all so the
Philippines was a very different
experience because I got to talk to him
I actually flew out there and like he
took leave for a week and I hung out
like that that didn't happen on any
other deployment that he had been
previously no yeah and that's the thing
is
doesn't matter where you are you know
when you're in the military you're
flying in helicopters you're parachuting
you're diving like all these things are
you know they're all they're all risky
they're all it's all risky business we
mitigate the risk as much as we can but
his things can still happen so I know
there's stress when you're doing that
and then he comes home from that
deployment and he Flynn decides he's
going to get out
yeah I think it was that deployment I
can't remember it all just melts
together it's like six years of just
straight chaos
um but yeah he decides he's gonna get
out he had always had a dream
um I mean part of it even going in the
SEAL Teams he was going to get out of
the military he was going to do one more
stent and then get out he was he was on
a ship prior to that he just realized he
went to the he went into the military
just to get through school and cover
school
um ROTC program because he's one of
eight and they just didn't have money
for college so he's like cool I can go
this way and kind of bankroll college
um and then he realized that
he didn't want his Navy time to be what
he had experienced prior to that it just
not that it was a bad thing at all he
just wanted to do more he didn't want
that to be his lasting Legacy was like
oh I spent a couple years on a ship and
then you know pushed off so he ended up
I think correct me if I'm wrong but
Flynn was like in the Persian Gulf wow
it was like it was like literally while
I was in ramadi and he's like seeing
reports of what's going on and seeing
the news and he just kind of said to
himself I gotta I gotta try and do that
yeah and so he kind of put the package
in and went that route but he always had
the desire to go on and do something
else when that was over so he knew he
wasn't necessarily going to be a lifer
especially as an officer like you get to
a certain point where you don't get to
do the things that you loved doing and
he always knew that he had another route
he wanted to take so he ended up
applying to a couple Business Schools
and wanted to go get his Masters so we
left San Diego and drove cross country
to Boston with our two boys and kind of
changed up everything at that point
because you just ditched your job yeah I
was not happy about this move I wanted
to support him but I was kind of stoked
he was getting out of the Navy that's
got to be a little bit of a relief for
you kind of but not really
I mean yes yes and no I mean you you
build up such a it's such a strong
community that there's such a high sense
of Pride and I had learned so much that
at this point
um I was a lot more comfortable in that
setting and not that I wanted him going
off to war and I didn't want the chance
of him not coming home but there was
just a real pride in what we were doing
and now we're leaving I'm leaving a job
I loved that I would have stayed at
Forever
um where I have I feel like I have a lot
of value like I'm valued in this role
and I just felt comfortable there and my
kids were set up in a really good
situation they went to the the daycare
on campus which was incredible
um and I just had really good
relationships and if I'm being honest
there was probably a little bit of
resentment because I had like already
everything that I cared about or I
thought I cared about in college like
just made a shift because now we're just
focusing on Flynn's going through buds
Flynn's becoming a CEO Flynn's deploying
and so everything was always the second
seat to what he was doing and now once
again we were uprooting our lives and
going cross-country to support him and
so it was just a transition that I had
to make and it took me a little while it
coupled with like now I go to this
prestigious University and
people are like find out I'm a mom and
then like conversation ends and they're
like oh cool and then they want to move
on to something more interesting so now
I'm like I left this career and now I'm
like the stay-at-home mom supporting my
husband while he goes through college
and I wasn't super happy with that role
yeah it was it was it was a it took me a
couple months to get comfortable there
that was the attitude you got huh yeah
it was like
yes especially early on because all the
students are just trying to meet the
other students and there's all these
things that we do when you get there say
that they do as part of onboarding and
orientation and things like that there's
all these different events and you know
people would be having a conversation
with you and they'd be like oh so what
do you do and it was like oh well you
know I was in this but now I'm home with
my kids and they're like oh cool so
um who are you and it was like all of a
sudden I'm like no like I I do cool
stuff too like I've had a career like it
just was difficult it was a lot of a lot
of ego uh for on my side that I had to
manage because I was like struggling
yeah I've got to admit I've adopted uh
my son and his buddies will use the term
yo at this point for like for like
everything every reaction that they give
so I'm I'm doing that it's kind of
grabbing me so when you tell me that
someone's like oh nice to meet you bye
yeah I'm like yo
so he's going to college and then
you're you're living I mean it's not
cheap to live in Boston and no what's
his job does he have a job no is he
getting GI bottle do you have GI Bill
yeah yeah yeah okay so he's got GI Bill
yellow ribbon and all that yeah he uh we
yeah we depleted our savings in the two
years that we were in Boston
um and in once I got past the initial
shock of just this new life and hating
everyone yeah yeah
I loved it it was such a cool experience
because it was the first time that Flynn
was home a lot so now like Nico would
get on his little bike and he'd ride
from our little apartment that was on
campus across to where Flynn would have
his break in between classes and he'd
bring him an energy drink goes weren't
out at this time but he would bring him
an energy drink in a book and Flynn
would spend his break reading and and
you know drinking this energy drink and
then Nico would ride back and he would
come home for lunch and then go lay down
with Brendan and put Brennan down and
then go back to class and so all of a
sudden it went from like he's never
around ever to he's here a lot like I
see him in the morning he's coming home
at lunch I see him again at night um but
I started to figure out like I I made
friends so that really helped and I
started to get a little more comfortable
with like just having time with my kids
that I hadn't had previously and then in
my true nature I just started finding
things I could do so I started helping
with various things on campus I got into
some event planning on campus Flynn came
home with a project and I basically did
it so I just started like cool I can
still have all this stuff and I'll just
find ways to satisfy like the
challenging component that I needed and
as you as Flinch kind of wrapping up
there is when life came out to talk to
Flynn and be like hey Flynn you know
we've got this thing going to National
on front what do you think you know when
you graduate from school maybe you come
by and we could see if you want to work
with us
and you're like eavesdropping on this
conversation or something no so lathe
came to dinner at our house but Brendan
I don't know what he had done but for
whatever reason I had to take him taking
the emergency room he needed like a
stitch or something uh just you know uh
boys two boys I had my third daughter at
that point too my third child uh my
daughter
um so I had to leave so I didn't stay
for dinner
um so I like said hi to Leif and then I
was out with Brennan like managing
whatever injury he had
um and I got home and Flynn was telling
me about their conversation and this
company I shot on front in this book and
what you guys were doing and he and I
was like oh cool and he was like yeah he
was kind of trying to you know see if I
was interested but at that point he had
already committed to this other
consultancy and like had a path
um and he was like you should reach out
like I you'd love what they're doing and
I was like I don't know and I thought
about it for about a half an hour and I
was like you know what I'm going to and
I sent laith an email I think it was
that night and I just said hey I had
this great conversation with Flynn and
he told me about what you guys are doing
and I don't know what you're looking for
or if I even and what you're looking for
but if there's an opportunity we are
leaving this stint and I'm kind of
looking for my next mission and I love
to talk to you about it
what did you think he wanted
I had no idea no idea I saw him two
weeks later we were in New York and we
went to brunch with him and his wife and
we had a conversation again at that
point and that's when he kind of told me
hey
I got your email like if I'm being
honest what I need right now is probably
like part-time maybe maybe 10 hours
maybe 20 hours but it's kind of like
admin because I had sent in my resume
and like did this whole thing and um and
we had this conversation and I was like
you know what I don't I don't know what
I want to do I can go back to higher
education but I'm just kind of looking
for something that's that challenge so
if you're open to it I'd be open for
some part-time work and and that'll give
me some time to kind of figure out what
I really want to do so I just was stoked
about what you guys are building even
just without really understanding what
it was at the time I was just excited so
I was willing to kind of take the
part-time job
um
to just you know see if it worked out
yeah and they've somehow convinced me to
tell you because I never want to hire
anybody
I was adamant he sent me and he
forwarded me an email what did I say he
forwarded me an email he he was like
this is from 2014 and it was something
along the lines of gosh I wish I could
remember the terminology but it was some
legal legal description for you and it
was like
general labor should we oh yes we put
her as should this should this
description be you know employee or
should it be general labor and I just
wrote back two words I wrote back
general labor that's it
that's a fair description in the early
days of bachelorette so that's what you
did you came on and you started kind of
like just doing admins because the
discussion I had with life was like we
could really we could really use someone
to help us you know uh uh book our
travel and stuff I was like book your
own travel
I'm like I'm booking my own travel you
can book your own travel be fine and you
know he's kept just kept at it and
eventually was like all right cool I
figured he's not gonna be
pestering me that much and you know in
typical um
typical fashion his he was able to
articulate good reasons and I wasn't
able to articulate reasons Not So
eventually you got to say okay this
might be a better plan than mine which
is my plan was just a BTF on and just
keep doing everything ourselves so he he
won that and and we brought you on as
just doing like travel I don't know what
else you were doing you're doing like
travel I didn't talk to you I didn't
care I was like I don't need this
support maybe you should pay for this
girl life maybe that's what you should
do
I don't think I talked to you for like
the first year
like even in person like you were always
cordial you always nice and you weren't
like mean or rude by any means but there
was definitely a little bit of like a
we'll see about this like I I could feel
it I was like all right
um but I'd worked a lot with Leif and I
was doing like literally some of the
most menial mundane admin tasks
um and I took on some other jobs too
some part-time jobs because I was paying
for full-time child care but like
working at Echelon front like five or
ten hours a week
um and so I picked up a job at Tiffany
and Company and I was doing some stuff
with them that was kind of like I just
had to go monthly and I did a lot of
design uh in their like window displays
and things of that nature so I just was
taking on little projects uh to to
manage like the full-time cost of
sending my kids to child care and I
remember Flynn was like hey how long are
we gonna do this you know and he was
good with it he was very supportive but
it was a valid question and I was like
you know what just give me six months at
this point I had been with you guys for
like six months I'm like just give me
six months and you know and then I'll
make a decision if things happen it
progressed or I don't have an
opportunity to grow here like we'll
we'll make a decision and it wasn't long
after that that the book came out and
like everything changed yeah and when
the book came out that was kind of my I
don't know if I met you before that or
talked to you before that but it wasn't
when the book came out was sort of like
the first time I saw your capabilities
and I was super stoked because you were
because it was like it's three hours of
sleep a night it was you know all day
long tight pressure timelines everything
had to be organized and I remember you
but I don't remember this but I remember
we have like the Saint Martin's press
guy who's a good guy but I was I
remember like looking at you like what
you tell me and he was kind of like like
you were getting in on his Rice Bowl
because you proved to me pretty quick
that you know what's going on and you
can handle it you could be making things
happen so that was definitely left a
really awesome impression on me the way
you handled we probably did in seven
days we probably did
you know well so many yeah so many
little movements and to the different
place and to the radio station and the
TV place and to the interview place and
and then the dinner thing and like just
all that stuff going on and I didn't
think about anything all I did was do
what you told me to do which as you know
now like that's that's how I roll like
you I'm not looking about what's going
on I'm not getting into the details and
stuff you tell me where to go put a mic
in my hand and I'm gonna rock and roll
that's what I'm gonna do Echo Charles
so as soon as I realized oh she gets it
like she understands how to make this
stuff happen
and like you you did exactly what we
needed and so after that I was I was
super stoked and and then I think you
just started to take things this is sort
of the you know when I did that intro
talking about the principles and how you
utilize the principles what you started
doing is taking ownership of things
taking ownership of things that were
important things that you knew you could
control and get in order
and that's what you did and every time
you grabbed you know project a and you
had control over it and it worked and it
was like oh Project B is over there
let's take that one and then project C
and I'm like hey we got Project D Jamie
can you do this too and you're like oh
I'm already on it
and so then it was just an escalation
you know if you would it's such a good
lesson learned for people you you
literally were hired part-time as to do
admin work and you just started taking
ownership dominating crushing and the
more you crushed and the more you took
ownership of the more ownership and
responsibility you got the more you did
and then you started I don't know how
long it was but all of a sudden you
looked at us like hey I need help
because once the book came out the
podcast came out and then it was it was
on like Donkey Kong and we started just
getting all kinds of work it was like a
month after that that Whirlwind of a
trip and I remember laith invited me
into the book launch and he was like hey
you should come out with us to New York
and like we started in Vegas who has had
a gig and it was your first like book
signing and keynote and then we ended up
going to New York from there and you're
right it was a total gut check and now
that you know what you know about me I
loved it I was like this is like total
chaos you're getting like no I remember
going to going back to my room I stayed
up with like a friend we had no money
like Echelon front didn't have money
back then I wasn't staying in some Posh
Hotel I stayed with a friend and I we
got back at like one after like all day
go and I had three hours to basically
sleep before I had to get back on the
subway and meet you guys and I she was
in like a New York apartment so no
windows and I shut the door and I
crashed and when I woke up I didn't know
where it was like I was just so tired
but it was like cool let's go um and you
really started to take a turn I didn't
know what I was intended to do during
the book launch I was like all right
Leif asked me to go oh there wasn't a
lot of guidance of like hey here's what
we need you to do so I just was like I
just need to be ready to answer any
questions I need to understand this
schedule so that I could help in
whatever was required of me and that
really was my Mantra through all of that
that first year and a half before the
book came out was like I'm just gonna
find a way to provide value because I
don't have a clear understanding of what
exactly I should be doing here but when
I saw a need I was like all right let me
just see if I can handle that and then
something would come up you know in
conversation or like well I could
probably do that let me try to figure
that out and just that continued over
time and then the book came out and it
was like a month later we started
getting calls from people to have you
guys out to speak and all of a sudden
that Cadence became significant I was
like Hey Leif I think this part-time gig
now now needs to be full time and it
went from like 20 hours a week to like
65 and like non-stop consuming all of my
waking hours and uh and it was maybe
eight months or nine months after that
that I finally was like Hey I'm gonna
need a little help if we're going to
continue doing this like I've reached a
capacity of things that I could take off
the plate because early on it was
marketing Finance accounting budgeting
sales Contracting I mean like the list
was endless of like what I was trying to
handle and I realized at a certain point
that I can't do all of this
yeah that was awesome it's an awesome
path for anyone to follow you know
anyone to follow you didn't have
experience in Finance marketing
Contracting all that other stuff you
didn't have any experience in that but
you took it you'd get help if you needed
to call a lawyer or call someone about
some contract you'd get that done but to
take ownership of it and and get the job
done using whatever means necessary
that's what you did and you just
you just started to grow and and
responsibility and then you started to
grow in your job as well and we started
to grow the company as we started to
grow the company you know all uh The
Tide Rises the boats all boats ride with
the rise with the tide that's what that
was you and it's a protocol that anybody
can follow I think I and one monster I
called the Jamie Cochran protocol like
go and start doing stuff and start
making it right and if you do that
you're gonna it's so obvious when people
you know we work with so many companies
if you're a if you're a highly motivated
person that will step in and take
responsibility and take ownership and
make things happen you're gonna rock and
roll people are gonna love having you
and they're gonna give you that
responsibility look if you take
responsibility for something and you
mess it up
yeah you could find yourself moving in
the other direction now if you if you
take responsibility and you mess up and
you say hey this is the mistake I made
it won't happen again then it's like
okay cool well let's make sure it
doesn't happen again and we move forward
and you can make up for that and go
beyond it but that idea of taking being
humble enough to take a job because you
know you had a pretty prominent job at
San Diego State University and you went
from that prominent job to a pretty
menial job first at Echelon front and
you were humble enough to do that you
didn't complain about it I never I
haven't actually didn't think I've ever
seen you complain anyways to this day so
you didn't complain about it you just
did it and you did it well you know
what's funny is you don't like doing
paperwork do you
um
not my thing not my thing yeah and like
I didn't know that until like three
years ago like three years ago I was
like oh she doesn't like doing paperwork
she's like me I always thought you were
like into it you were one of those
people no I you know to the point you
just made you can't deny performance you
can't deny it and to your guys's credit
you guys gave me so much leeway like I
would say hey I was thinking about
taking this on you'd be like yeah go for
it like there was just a lot of autonomy
which I loved and really you guys set me
up for failure because I was like well I
have to make it work at National Park
because I can't go back to like the red
tape that you get on a college campus
um and you want to talk about paperwork
there's a lot of that there
um but no I I'm not really one for the
details I can do it and I did do it you
definitely did it you have to like hone
in on the paperwork and the details and
those types of things but where I really
love sitting is the brainstorming and
the thinking and the solving problems
and the big picture I love that piece of
it but early on at us on front there
wasn't a lot of capacity for that
because we had all these small or
tactical things that had to get done and
then obviously as our team has grown in
nine years I just keep hiring people
that are way better at the details in
the paperwork than I am so that they can
handle those things and we got you know
Jen Tarantino who's a freaking like
Warrior when it comes to like the
details and the paperwork and the just
the the logistics which enables me to
actually do what I like which is just to
think big picture
so
we get done with 2015 then 2016 is when
we did our first muster which it was
kind of like what was it August was when
we decided to do it it was September or
yeah we I think we decided in August and
then the event happened in October I
think okay yeah so it was something like
a short Turner sure turn around you
luckily you had experience in event
planning I don't know if you and Leif
really wanted to do it
yeah yeah I remember a phone call and
like we had been talking about it like
vaguely and then finally the three of us
were on a call and it was like hey we
want to do this event we want to do it
in October we want to do it in San Diego
and we want like 350 people can you make
that happen and I was like
yeah yeah I can make that happen and
inside I'm like I don't know if I can
make this happen this seems like a
really tight time frame
um but we pulled it together it turned
out awesome we sold out of that out yeah
we had 365 people at that first event
and it felt like like we made it yeah
that was epic yeah I I remember from my
perspective I was like Hey worst case
scenario
32 people show up at this thing and
they're gonna have literally the best
event they've ever had in their life and
they'll be stoked and we'll lose some
money but we'll you know we'll figure it
out and you're like okay cool fair
enough let's rock and roll I was like
managing this budget to like the penny
because my biggest fear was like I can't
have the first program the first big
project they give me be a failure and so
I'm like how many tickets do we need to
sell that at least it's a wash I just
don't want to go into the red and I had
like this like very detailed budget and
I was tracking every single thing and we
had nothing established we didn't know
what the two-day agenda was gonna look
like we didn't know what kind of Auto
visual we wanted there was so many
things that came out of that first
semester like the music we play in
between sets and walk-in and things of
that nature
um like merchandise was a new thing for
us we never had any of that there were
just so much in that first Muster that
is awesome because we've evolved so much
but it really set the stage and there's
still things that we learned in that
first mushroom we Implement now that
just worked and that's that's where I
think from a leadership perspective when
you execute things and you're going to
take some risks to execute things
sometimes the the downside because you
executed quickly the downside because
you didn't have maybe things fully
planned out the upside is the lessons
that you learned because you can't learn
lessons you can't learn all the lessons
unless you execute so actually executing
something and that's one of the things
that drove me to execute that thing was
like oh I know if we do this we're going
to learn a bunch we're going to learn a
bunch we're going to learn how to do it
and then it's going to be one step
closer to being a lot better whereas
just sitting around and brainstorming
like well what do you think it'll be
like when we do a two-day schedule like
no let's make a two-day schedule let's
execute this thing and then you figure
out hey this was a little too much or do
a little bit less of that or a little
bit more of that so I think Lee leaning
towards executing as long as you can
mitigate the risk you know somewhat then
then take a shot take a crack at it
that's what we're doing
um and that's what we did and what what
monster are we on now how many coming up
on Master 17 Master 17 and to your point
we haven't stopped learning like I
remember after that muster there was a
ton of Lessons Learned and then we did
it again and there was more Lessons
Learned and we did it again and there
was more Lessons Learned and even to
this last event muster 16 we debriefed
after and there was like okay there's a
couple things we can we can still tweak
there's always little things every
muster we've added something or done
something based on feedback from
attendees and observations from the team
so that debrief has been awesome because
every event just gets better yeah that
being said the learning curve on the
first like three or four monsters was
insane I remember Leif and I were up in
New York City our second muster it's two
o'clock in the morning we have to get up
at three o'clock in the morning to PT
and we're signing certificates
and it was just like yo
yeah leave always brings up that story
because there was a bunch of
certificates that have been duplicate
printed so he just was like it's you
guys just want to get get done and he's
seeing like John seven times and he's
just like oh my gosh
um that was a big one I mean that was
the first time we had JP and Dave on
stage so that was a learning curve I was
super sick at that muster like really
it's like we got the day kicked off and
I like went up to the room and took a
nap because I was like very sick and it
was it that that second one was my least
favorite muster even though it was the
first time with Dave and JP it was it
was cool yeah and it was awesome being
in New York kind of like there was not
there's a lot of things that are
negative about New York but there's also
some awesome things about being in New
York City that was cool uh then you when
did you talk because you because you
ended up eventually
because listen as I'm watching this I'm
seeing that you know we have zero
employees than we have you then also we
have three then all of a sudden we have
five then also we have seven then we
have you know we're bringing instructors
on like this is growing and so what I'm
getting to see this whole time is you
utilizing the principles that we sit
around and talk about that you had to
sit there and listen to it you had to
sit there and read and I saw you
utilizing them like and for me there's a
there's a you know Alan Belcher Jiu
Jitsu yes MMA yes sir
when he fought against taquinho you know
takinyo is yeah he was a guy that was a
brutal leg Locker brutal leg locker and
they were fighting in the UFC and Alan
Belcher
had Dean Lister go down and spend like a
month training him for leglocks
and everyone was absolutely horrified of
tokino's leg locks he had hurt people
and he was kind of like a little bit
crazy where when he would get a heel
hook or something he would crank it and
hurt people so everyone was kind of
scared of him
and I'd actually had one of my guys
Thomas draval fought him and got heel
hooked in the first round and like it
hurt like injury like the whole nine
yards so Alan Belcher is going to fight
tequino
and he hires Dean Lister Dean Lister
goes down and trains him on how to
defend leglocks and then I'm watching
the fight on UFC and I it was it was the
coolest thing because I'm watching Alan
Belcher and I'm like oh he's gonna if
he's doing this right oh there's the
defense oh yeah but and I could see that
he was literally taking Dean's
principles and just putting him to work
and he beat he he got out of every heel
hook attempt and he was like he was kind
of like being uh provocative about it
like oh try and heal hook me or try and
foot lock me and and so can you couldn't
get it and he ended up Alan Belcher won
the fight it was awesome
but I remember watching going oh I know
exactly what that is that I see what
you're doing there I see what you're
doing now in Belcher oh there's the next
move I can see what he was doing you
could see what he had learned
and I got to watch you apply these
things and I'd be like I don't know
actually exactly what she's doing well
she's using decentralized command over
there oh she's got prioritized execute
and I was watching you do this you know
for a year two years three years and at
some point Leif and I are talking like
you know
kind of cool to get Jamie to get up
there and talk about some of these
principles from her perspective and also
be cool to get that you know someone
that's not in the military up there
because we have you know me Dave JP Leif
we're all military background and we're
sitting here preaching to people that
this stuff works in any environment well
it's nice to get someone that's from a
different environment get up there and
and tell what it's like and how it is
from the pure civilian perspective So
eventually what was it it was in
Australia is the first time you got up
on there right yeah the conversation to
come up a couple months before that and
I was like yeah yeah it just kind of
like sure guys and and we didn't really
talk about it again and then when we
were getting ready for Australia it was
the Prime opportunity because we weren't
taking the entire crew we were taking a
more condensed crew because we're
obviously going all the way to Australia
and it was expensive so it got brought
up again and I finally was like all
right like we'll give this a try and I
prepped for my first brief brief at that
muster and I gave my first keynote there
uh and I was terrified why were you
terrified
I'd rather get up there and sing a song
I think it was just like
it was just like it wasn't necessarily
the stage it wasn't even the audience it
was two things one it was my first time
so there's just a lot of pressure I
think I gave that brief like 47 times
before I ever went on stage my parents
probably heard it like 12 times because
I was like can I run my brief for you
again uh and so I just was really
practiced and I wanted to make sure I
did well the biggest challenge or the
reason why it was so difficult was it
wasn't the audience it wasn't the stage
it was the fact that sitting stage right
was you and laith and Dave and JP and
these people that I highly respected and
valued and I didn't want to let you down
and I didn't want to do a disservice to
the content that we teach because I
believed in it and I I wholeheartedly
wanted to help people understand that
these principles apply in every aspect
and I was I think a little Fray afraid
that I would somehow not do the message
Justice
well you kind of knocked it out of the
park didn't you
I thought you did the crowd thought you
did
you obviously got repeat performances
now you're a staple yeah a staple of
that and and from there once you did
that
you know now you're a full-on instructor
at Echelon front
um and you had to do a couple things to
make that happen well number one you you
kept you you know you went and expanded
from like oh well Jamie can do that
keynote yup Jamie can actually do a
little bit of a workshop and then all of
a sudden you're doing that stuff
you also had to build a team that could
do everything that you were doing that
could cover for all that other stuff so
that you could go out and do the
instructor type stuff so you you had a
it was a it was pretty quick though you
did that pretty quickly that
transformation yeah it was like over a
year well and we had been slowly
building the team at that point anyways
and up until that point like I I got a
lot of credit for the musters people
would come out and be like man that was
awesome you run a crate event and I I
always wanted to be like no no you don't
understand like there is a team of
people that are managing this that are
making me look good
um and we're just lucky because the
people that come to these events make
this atmosphere very unique compared to
other environments so like we could be
mediocre and the event would still be
amazing because people show up and they
just are engaged um so there was just
there was already this team Dynamic and
people on the team that were stepping up
and taking over responsibilities to the
point where I could even be on stage in
Australia whereas like four musters
prior to that there's no way I could
have done that because I was in the
background managing all of that that uh
the responsibilities and then over time
every muster I had less and less and
less to do
kind of like echo echo shows up you know
with this camera and then oh at the
monster yeah he just walks around
holding it he's not actually taking
footage he's actually signing books and
and he's you know just with the people
but but over time that happened with me
the muster I had less and less to do
um and so it opened the pathway for me
to actually think more about what it
would be like to be an instructor and I
realized
I realized after that first semester
that when people look at you and Lace
they see something that maybe is like
they can't achieve and so what I
provided was a different perspective and
the recognition that like hey I'm not
like these seasoned combat veterans that
I work with I'm just a regular person
just trying to become a better mom and
trying to implement these principles in
my business and how I lead my life and
people saw themselves in me and so I I
got over that imposter syndrome of is
there you know what am I doing trying to
teach this message to you know what I
have some value to add I have a
perspective that I think could help
people yeah and like I said you put this
stuff to work I mean you're talking
about the muster the first four monsters
you were kind of in the weeds and you
had to do stuff the fifth muster maybe a
little less the six month or you don't
do anything now with the monster no I
get in my team's way I'm like hey guys
and Jen's like no no we got it and then
I'm like well what about this she's like
we got it and I'm like you know what
I'll just be over here if you need
anything yeah and what that is is that's
decentralized command yeah that's making
sure that everyone understands what
mission is that's cover Move that's
everyone understanding what the
priorities are like those are the
principles being executed the monster is
a great example I mean I use the muster
as an example at the muster because it
truly does represent the principles it's
really obvious everyone's there
everyone's like the crowd is sitting
there and it's like oh all this stuff I
didn't do anything I didn't do all I did
was show up they put a microphone on me
I would walk out there and talk that's
literally all I have to do there's all
this AV setup there's meals there's PT
happening there's gift bags for
everybody there's the Run of show and
the slot like all the stuff I don't do
anything I don't do anything
and and now you don't do anything either
barely so so when you talk about oh you
can just give your perspective that's
cool but also you can literally speak to
the fact of how these principles work
for you and the other thing that's cool
about being an instructor at Echelon
front is you get to work with other
companies and when you work with other
companies you start to see
when they start to implement the
principles you start to get the feedback
from them and they see how it works and
now you have more tools to be able to
explain these principles and how they
function in different environments so
it's a it's a pretty cool growth for you
to go to to make that transition but
it's also a really obvious move it's re
it seems real obvious now it might not
have seemed obvious to you at some point
but like when I when you got done it in
Australia
actually before you even got done I was
like oh you know I watch you operate I
know what you do I understand that you
understand I know that you
deeply understand what it means to take
extreme ownership I know that you fully
recognize what it means to cover Move
Like These are things that
you can answer any question about so I
think it's a it's an obvious move I'm
glad you're there now
oh yeah I love it now I I still get
nervous and it's still you guys because
I go speak to companies all the time I
did a keynote yesterday and it's like no
factor it's just get up you talk about
it I I love the stuff I'm when I'm
speaking about it it's authentic because
I've seen it in my own life literally
transformed the way that I handle
challenges and problems and so I believe
it and so it's very natural and and easy
to give a keynote and then we get to the
muster and people are like why are you
so nervous I'm like it's you it's like
it's you guys because it's probably that
same sense I talked about earlier with
my dad of like I just didn't want to let
him down I have that same sense of uh
you know significance with the echelon
front team I just don't want to let you
guys down or disappoint you by not
following through and doing the things
that we're supposed to do so if I'm ever
teetering on like not following the
principles it's like I always go right
back to it because I'm like I can't be
here as a part of this company and
managing this Mission or helping to
support this mission of helping people
learn these principles if I'm not not
applying them in every single aspect of
my life
yeah this uh being in Echelon front is a
very difficult place to make excuses
yeah it's just like it just doesn't work
out very well uh then what do we do we
did Jocko live which is another I threw
Jocko live at you with how far in
advance was that right before we left
for Australia it was like December like
maybe November 30th or something but
right before we left for Australia you
were like I don't even know how it came
about somebody had the idea and we're
like all right we're gonna do this the
Jocko live tour uh in January we did six
shows and so we had a month to prepare
for that while we were in Australia for
basically two weeks doing the muster and
then Christmas and we came back from
Christmas and it was like boom we went
six weeks in a row six different shows
we got more Jocko live coming up by the
way I haven't even talked about it I
keep forgetting to talk about it I'm
very bad at advertising they're close to
sold out so you gotta get your tickets
so what is it it's it's Ann Arbor
Michigan it's shy Town yep it's Boston
and where's the last silly and Philly
yeah that's right this July 7th and 8th
and the 21st 22nd yeah so if you want to
come check out a Jocko live it's just me
um talking playing guitar
we can add that into the second round
but that first round was so cool because
you if you don't know what Draco life is
and I think people it's a cool way for
people to introduce you to people in
their life that may not listen to the
podcast but every show is unique which I
thought was so crazy you could have
easily done the exact same thing at six
shows and it would have no one would
have ever noticed but you like based on
the city you were in your intro was
different for every single show some of
the core of it was kind of the same but
uh I just was so fascinated going on
tour with you and I was like I cannot
believe like the imagination never stops
with you there's always something
different like just when I think I've
learned it all I've heard you talk for
nine years nearly every single day and
then you say something and I'm like gosh
damn it like there's another good thing
I gotta write this down like it's it's
crazy yeah the Jocko live things are
awesome there you how many people
they're like a thousand maybe 1500
people yeah these venues are between a
thousand and I think 1800. I'm not a
diva I'll like hang out someone just
sent me a message like hey can I is it
possible that I could please you know
meet you at this thing I'm like yeah 100
I'm gonna be walking around out front
you know I'm not like in the green room
with cucumbers on my eyes the way Echo
Charles usually is you actually get in
trouble at those venues because you hang
out beforehand and they're like
panicking because like we have to start
the show and people can't get to their
seats because Jocko's in the aisle way
and I'm like yeah yeah I got him and
then after the show you know we'll tell
them and I will prep them hey we're
gonna be here for a long time because
people he's gonna he's gonna meet every
single person that wants to meet him
that night and take a picture and sign a
book and they're like well how long and
I'm like we could go till 11. there was
a couple shows I think we hit midnight
and the venue's like oh my gosh can we
get out of here you know they're so
pissed um but that's who you are and I
think um yeah it was people coming to
those events are wanting to meet you
that's what that's why they come so the
fact that you stick around and do it is
cool it was hype for you too because at
the muster you've got audio visual
you've got all these people you've got
all these meals you got all those things
going on at at Jocko live I'm like can
you get me a table Yeah a chair
and I'm good and a microphone and so
it's it's definitely a different vibe
and I'll do q a too I do q a so if you
got questions you can ask them you know
there so anyways we got chocolate live
coming up you you managed to get that
thing together it was all by the way
super spreader events because it was
just before covid and it was crazy
because we went to like every coveted
Town it was before covid like no one had
heard of covid but we finished in
February like February 28th or something
was the last show in San Francisco so we
did San Francisco New York DC awesome we
went to every place that of two weeks
later was completely shut down from
covid we were there hugging growing out
with people just getting after it and so
I felt like if there was a patient zero
and it happened to be me I was like if
they pulled a string on this I might be
the guy but especially that San
Francisco show because you were sick
like you like you almost lost your voice
and I was like I hope you can make it
through this show
maybe I wouldn't have been surprised but
I remember when like things started
happening at like a couple weeks later
it was really closely after it was a
couple weeks and they're talking about
it and I was like uh we were just in San
Diego with a thousand people and you
were sick yeah yeah the San Diego show
was sick you were yeah yeah that was our
last show
Oh I thought San Francisco was that's
what I meant I'm sorry San Francisco
okay yeah I still have funny flashbacks
when
um my oldest daughter and I would be
arguing about the coronavirus and we
would in the middle of like a heated
argument my daughter would be like
listen dad the fact of the matter is
Miss Rona exists and I'd be like yeah
but you can't blame everything on Miss
Rona we would still call it Miss Rhoda
all right and then speaking of kovid
that was a wild time yep that was a wild
time in Echelon front so Echelon front
99 of our engagements in March of 2020
were live face to face going into
companies sitting down working with them
and then
March 15th comes and I think we had how
many events do we have canceled four
months in the first month of like the
world shutting down we had 37 different
events that were canceled
um or like they were like hey we gotta
postpone we got to put this on hold
several companies panicked and they were
like we just need to cancel there was a
lot of them millions and millions of
dollars worth of Revenue Gone Gone
and up until that point we had never
explored virtual training and I think we
all had this feeling that like you can't
be effective virtually so we weren't
really doing it and I think we always
felt like this sense of like no in
person is the way to go and then all of
a sudden it was like well I guess we
can't do that so what's next we we had
explored it and the reason we explored
it because we had a base level platform
and the reason we had that was because I
had a client and I went to this client
and he and he said I want you to teach
every person in my company and I think
they had 150 000 people globally oh yes
you're talking about the EF online yeah
yeah so we so we had kind of started to
do that we had a we had a platform but
like I said it was being utilized one
percent of the time
and what I was
I was totally forgot about EF online at
that time because it was still very new
and if in its infancy but as far as like
us going on site with clients we weren't
doing any of that virtually everything
was like no no being in person is really
where you get you know we had all these
activities that required discussion and
things like that and there's also a
hurdle to get over because clients would
be like what you do what do you mean
video like what do you mean how does
that even work like so
people didn't want to do it yep people
said no you fly out here you fly to New
York you fly to Chicago we want to hear
you talk and then that was the awesome
thing about covid was all of a sudden in
two weeks every single person in the
world was doing video teleconferencing
video conferencing video presentations
and now it's just normal and that was
such a huge hurdle to overcome and open
people's minds to this is a way to do
this and there's actually some things
about online training
that's better you know for instance if
I'm doing an online if I'm doing a
presentation and I go and there's three
thousand people in the crowd the people
in the back row you know what are they
seeing they're guess what they're
staring at they're staring at the big
video monitor anyways but there's no
real interaction
and then when I'm doing a a presentation
of 3000 people over the over a web
presentation whether it's
teams or Zoom or Skype or whatever
I'm looking at them like look you can't
put 3 000 people on the screen but you
those 40 people those 40 little faces
you're getting more feedback from them
than you are when you're staring at the
bright lights giving a presentation to
3000 people so there's some real
advantages also doing the Q a look you
can do q a live and people can stand but
you don't get any screening of those
questions whereas if you have people
submitting questions into a chat room
there's someone that's filtering through
those questions figuring out what the
best questions are you're in an awesome
place so there's some actual things
about virtual presentations and virtual
events that are better now listen
there are some things about live
presentations that are better too
you get that human interaction you get
that energy you get to real time
engagement that's human so there's
advantages and disadvantages to both but
they're both really super positive and
there's really
they both have some positives but
there's no real like negatives to either
one of them there's no like hey this is
actually the the real downfall of
virtual there's no real downfall there's
no real downfall to live presentations
they both have some some higher
advantages but the base level of both
those things is outstanding which is
what the world learned from covert well
the benefit for us is that we start we
made the quick pivot to Virtual we
started doing free we remember we were
doing three times a week free sessions
and you could just join well I thought
you were going to talk about the amount
of stuff we did for clients no we
started doing that too we just started
doing free stuff because our Theory and
you said very early on when I would call
you and I'd be like hey we had another
client they want to cancel their
contract this was before the world knew
like everything's gonna shut down so
there's a lot of fear of like okay do I
just void this contract do I just let it
go like do we hold them to terms like I
didn't know how you wanted to handle
that and I would call you the first
couple times and you'd say
finally you were like hey relationships
are Paramount and you gave me that one
Mantra and I was like okay I can run
with that I understand your intent I can
now make decisions to prioritize our
clients and so very quickly the whole
team started to do that where we shifted
to Virtual sessions oftentimes for free
we started just reaching out to our
entire list of clients just checking in
and and making ourselves available I
know Dave did a big effort on that and I
actually talked to clients on the phone
they would call with challenges that
they were dealing with all through covid
and we had most of those contracts that
were canceled came back around at some
point and we were able to fulfill them
whether virtually in fact we had I think
seven leadership development and
Alignment program clients our big
contracts that we do over the course of
a long term our long-range training
programs all seven clients pivoted to
Virtual and we didn't lose a single one
and we were able to be effective at
training them in a virtual setting and
the benefit to us is over that time
first of all I got
an immense amount of training myself
because I got to sit with you guys three
times a week and listen to this
um and I got to practice because I
started doing some of those sessions but
then at the end result for Echelon front
was now we figured out you got in person
in Virtual and the real power is kind of
when you use both and you go do it in
person and then you do a virtual
follow-up like now we can do more with
the client that we couldn't do
previously because budgets didn't allow
for us to come four different times or
get other people or take their people
offline we could do a in-person session
and then send them to the academy for
really amazing courses and continuation
or we could do live virtual sessions
that are a deeper dive into what we're
teaching and we could have a lot more
impact with our clients yeah it's a
little it's literally crazy to think
about the number of times that I have
flown to New York City or flown to
Chicago Orlando
or flown anywhere to give a one hour
presentation
and so it takes me to go to New York
this is like a 48 hour at a minimum to
get out there because you can't like
leave it to last minute you got to get
out there early which means a day early
which means you're flying out early and
then you got to get a hotel and then
you're staying in the hotel and then you
go go there and you're gonna get one
hour from me so they're they're get
they're pulling me offline for 48 to 72
hours
to get a one-hour thing meanwhile covet
hits I'm on a zoom call and I'm giving
the same presentation
and it takes me literally one hour and
seven minutes because I'm gonna get on
early make sure everything's squared
away give the presentation answer
questions and we're all good to go and
you're gonna do four of those or five of
those in a day yep it's like crazy how
much it helped our capacity and and
helped us by everyone understanding that
virtual is a thing it's a positive thing
there's positives to it it has the same
impact or it has it has an equally
strong impact there are some there's
something live look when live events
started kicking back off and I was going
to Live Events again and we're going to
Live Events now there's a certain level
of look they get the camaraderie of the
team all coming together you know when
there's 800 people at this company and
they're all over the country and then
all of a sudden they're all in the same
room there's networking and relationship
building that happens and then we're
there to help help that out so there's
there's that side of it but man for to
get those 800 people and talk to them
six times instead of just once and have
them all on a zoom call at the same time
six times there there is some serious
positives to the virtual stuff as well
and that's why covid turned out to be a
positive thing for us yeah we like
tripled in size in like the three-year
span of covid it's crazy like we were
and at the same time doing a lot of free
stuff just prioritizing relationships
and yet we were growing
um and I think that was you know much to
your credit of like the quick pivot of
like all right the world shutting down
we've gotta innovate and adapt and
figure out another way and so let's
start doing these free sessions let's
put a lot more effort and energy into
the academy and kind of fortify some
virtual options for people let's you
know spend this time building some
additional curriculum and all of a
sudden we just you know everyone turned
and kind of ran ran quickly and we
started growing as a team I mean we
tripled tripled in size in that time
span yeah I don't know what my uh
predilection what's the word prediction
prediction no that's not it but anyways
I don't know what my sense was but I
remember saying this to the team hey we
don't know how long this is going to
last we can try and hold our breath
until it's over
but it might not be over and we might
run out of air and so let's just make an
adjustment right now and that's what we
did I mean we made an adjustment
immediately because it we didn't go oh
there's only two weeks to flatten the
curve okay we can hold our breath for
two weeks we didn't even do that we were
like we're changing right now we're
gonna start being proactive that was
definitely a very positive thing to do
because we were ahead of the curve we
were ahead of it which was which was
good when you
look at
let's let's take that a little bit but
just in general cover and move how does
it help you
relationships I think too often people
don't understand the value of what
positive relationships can provide you
there's you can get anything
accomplished if you have strong
relationships and I it's not something
people spend a lot of time prioritizing
or maintaining you know we get really
comfortable with our kids or our spouse
or our friends of just these established
relationships and yet we're not
prioritizing continuing to maintain or
build those relationships and with your
teammates there's nothing more powerful
than a team of people that care about
you and care about the mission and know
that you care about them so if I'm
putting my energy and effort in focusing
on the team and prioritizing the team
and doing what I can to build
relationships and support them that
level of trust is going to be far more
valuable than anything else that I could
do as far as hey I am your boss and this
is what we're doing
um and so it's it's just working
together as a team recognizing that we
have one Mission and we're all gonna
work together to accomplish that mission
yeah when we talk about building trust a
lot of times we had asked about building
trust and I think what I talked through
earlier was you
and let's take you and me as a as an
example I didn't know you I didn't trust
you I didn't know you I have no
relationship with you right I mean I
don't literally don't know who you are
and oh you're Flynn Cochran's wife and
he was at team one and and I know him
and he's a good dude okay cool this is
nothing I get that gives me zero to go
off of so I meet you and it's like oh
give a little bit of trust yep you take
that you prove you're good to go and by
the way when I give you a little bit of
trust I'm actually giving you it in a
way that you realized I am actually
giving you trust like hey oh you're
gonna let me do this project by myself
or you're gonna let me handle this thing
so this is where we talk about that the
building of trust it starts small and
then it just builds from there and it
snowballs it's like an exponent at least
for me
uh it's it's pretty exponential and well
so what did that look like from your
perspective
you early on you started and the way
that you built that trust was I would
call you and say hey how do you want me
to handle this and you would ask that
one question over and over and over
again what do you think we should do and
you would ask me that question and over
time I've realized okay I've just got to
come prepared with an answer or a plan
and so I would say hey here's the
problem here's what I think we should do
and 98 of the time you'd say cool
execute let me know how I can support
and that built up that confidence and
that trust in me and so you gave me so
much trust that over time
there's almost nothing I value more than
like the trust I get from people that I
care about and you gave me so much trust
in the beginning and even when I failed
even when I made mistakes you took
ownership of it or life took ownership
of it and I was like hold on guys I I
made this mistake that that continued to
build in that trust to now you've
created such a sense of loyalty I mean
we joke about just the the team has this
like real sense of loyalty to you and
nothing was more PR you know there was a
whole scenario where we got to see this
play out where everyone was like coming
to your defense because there is this
such such a strong sense of trust um and
it started from the beginning just
little ways in which you just let me run
with it and then you let me execute my
plans even though you probably had
better ideas on how to solve those
problems but you would just say execute
and you would just give me that trust to
go do it and over time that became
something that that I highly highly
value is your trust you know the
um lately I've been talking a lot about
the the extreme ownership leadership
Loop and the last thing that I consider
when I'm making a decision is how does
this impact my relationship and that's
the most it's the last thing I consider
but it's the heaviest weight of what I'm
considering and if I could conv if
hopefully I wrote about it from the new
version of leadership strategy and
tactics and hopefully I can convey it
strongly enough that if you put the
relationships as the priority it helps
so many decisions because just what
you're talking about you know you might
come to me and say hey Jocko I think for
Jocko live we should hand out uh these
uh uh small kettlebell keychains
right
and
I might be thinking like well that's an
extra expenditure or they're just going
to get lost they're not gonna be high
quality may not look that good or
whatever maybe look it's I don't even
think it's that bad of an idea but it's
like not the priority at all
and so I might think well hey Jamie I
think that's a waste of money or hey
Jamie I think it's gonna but what is
that worth
how does that show you what does that
show you my level of trust in you that
you came out with an idea you went and
sourced the way to make this happen you
put together the budget then you came
and presented me and said hey Joc we got
these cool kettlebell keychains that
we're gonna give out and I go
no I don't like that
so what does that what does that do you
all of a sudden I'm showing you that I
don't trust your judgment and really
what's the worst case scenario the worst
case scenario is people got a cool
keychain that that's like the worst case
scenario but because I don't think it's
a good idea it wasn't my idea I'm gonna
I'm gonna shut it down
and what I'm doing is I'm prioritizing
my ego I'm prioritizing my idea I'm
prioritizing my budget
over my relationship with you my trust
in you now listen if you came and say
hey we're going to give away a real
kettlebell you know a real 24 kilogram
kettlebell to every person that shows up
at Jocko live it's gonna be awesome and
I'll be like hey Jamie like can you run
the numbers on that because
those are expensive and they're also
hard to ship and also some people are
flying in and they'll have to fly home
with this one and I would ask you some
questions and then you'd be like you
know I ran the numbers on that we're
gonna go with a keychain instead right
but
just asking Earnest questions
prioritizing a relationship is such a
key component to Think Through there's
so many decisions that make themselves
there's so many decisions that make
themselves if you prioritize the
relationship over everything else now
listen like I said if you come to me
with an idea that's literally not going
to function
then I'm gonna have to ask you some
Earnest questions and and hopefully
you'll see like oh this doesn't make
sense now maybe there's something I
didn't think maybe you're like hey no
Jocko don't worry about it we got a
sponsor they're giving us all the
kettlebells for free we're getting 10
000 kettlebells they're for free they're
gonna ship for free we just gotta deal
with FedEx they're gonna ship it free
because they love they love Jocko and
they love what you're saying so we're
good to go and I'd be like wow awesome
everyone gets a free kettlebell yeah
everyone gets so if I ask an Earnest
question and you give me an answer I'm
ready to be like okay awesome let's
execute
so prioritizing the relationship so
important giving trust away is how you
get that trust back that's covered move
what about simple
for me simple in the way that we
typically teach it with clients is about
communicating effectively being simple
clear concise I think about simple as it
relates to the mission and plans the
mission has to be simple and I think
anyone at Echelon fund understands what
our mission is because it's simple clear
concise and we can execute towards that
mission and once the mission is simple I
can now focus on the plans and processes
and what we need to do to accomplish
that mission and those things need to
also be simple and I think that's what's
awesome about working with a team that
understands these principles because
we're very good at coming up with
simplified Sops simplifying processes
recognizing when something's too complex
and maybe the team can't execute because
they don't understand what's going on
and then ultimately once you have the
simple Mission simple plans to execute
on that mission you have to be able to
communicate that effectively in a simple
clear and concise manner and for me with
that what I've really learned is that I
have to I have to adjust the way I
communicate based on who I'm talking to
that's a component of symbols so the way
that I communicate with you versus life
is different the way that I may
communicate with Jen or with Jack is
different based on what I know about
them based on our relationships and so
that simple component is really that
test for me of am I communicating in a
way that is effective with this
particular individual or team
these uh the Instinct that human beings
have generally speaking to make things
more complex
is really a driving force in human
nature and look I got to see this in the
SEAL Teams these guys with these giant
brains and their ivy league education
and they'd come in with their
engineering degree and they would
formulate plans that were just
completely insane and so yes keeping it
keeping things simple and then the way
you communicate and yeah absolutely by
the way when I talk to the Troops
I'm I'm communicating in a certain way
when I talk to the Admiral I'm Computing
communicating in a different way the
content of what I'm saying is not
different so I'm not telling the troops
like hey this is a stupid thing to do we
shouldn't be doing it and then saying
the Admiral hey this is brilliant no I'm
not doing that I'm saying the troops hey
look I'm not 100 sure why this is going
on let me try and find some answers and
I'm saying the Admiral Hey sir I
actually need to find some answers about
why we're doing this because it doesn't
make sense to me right now I'm gonna
come in and look when I was talking to
troops I might drop a couple f-bombs
whatever we're talking in a different
we're we're using different
communication tools
that's not to say I'm telling two
different people two different things
it's not two-faced
to communicate in diff utilizing
different methodologies I actually was
telling Echo about this a while ago like
I
I would talk to the Admiral I would talk
to the captain I would talk to Mike
Manning officer I would talk to the
Troops I would walk out of a platoon
meeting
where I was
talking to them in their language to go
talk to the Admiral when I talked to him
in his language
I wasn't saying anything different
I was saying the same thing it's just in
a different language so that's what we
have to learn how to do when it comes to
simple communication you need to
communicate to people in their native
tongue whenever possible
and you need to not utilize language
that they don't understand that doesn't
make sense to them and by the way that's
up and down the chain of command you can
talk to there's things that an admiral
or things that a CEO will not understand
there's language that you can use that
they will not understand just like
there's language you can use to the
front line troops that they won't
understand so you as a leader have to be
I use this a lot you have to be a
translator of sorts because sometimes
I'm telling taking what the Admiral said
I'm translating it into what the troops
can understand sometimes in taking what
the troop said I'm translating it into
what the Admiral can understand that's
what we become we become a a filter that
provides Simplicity in language to the
audience that we're talking to so that's
a very astute
um perception you've got there Jamie
well I actually learned that early on
with you and laith because you're both
very different and so I figured out that
one you were really always busy and so I
wanted you to pick up the phone when I
called if I had a question so I realized
very quickly okay Jocko I need to speak
in bullet points and I could do that and
you wouldn't be offended you wouldn't be
like are you okay or is there something
wrong like you would just take it I
would just say hey a b c and you'd be
like yes no yeah let me think about it
and then we'd end the call and you
weren't short and it wasn't it wasn't a
detriment to our relationship I just
figured out early on that I could talk
to you in bullet points and we could
just get some stuff done and move on and
if I did that and I've managed that the
way I communicate with you based on your
schedule you pick up the phone every
time I called and in fact now people
will get a hold of me and be like hey
can you get a hold of Jocko because
you'll answer my call and then Leif
needs a lot more information I have to
anticipate that when I go into a
conversation with Leif we're going to
spend 20 minutes probably talking about
my family and what's going on and what I
did for the weekend and just that
southern hospitality it's just gonna be
a different conversation sometimes you
know late calls and I'll be like all
right how much time do I have and can I
take this but even with life like I will
know that I need to come in that
conversation prepared to answer
questions he's going to have and and
have a little more information for him
than I may need for you but I figured
out very early on that if I tried to
communicate that way with you you would
be like hey I don't have time for this
so I just had to adjust you you it's up
to you when you're communicating to
adjust to the person that you're talking
to and too often we think it's up to
them like I'm communicating clearly and
then I'm being frustrated because my
team's not doing what I ask them to do
and it's like well probably because of
the way you communicated it you didn't
think about the the receiving end of
that and what it how it comes across
Jack prioritize and execute
detaching from emotion
there's a million things at any given
time that I have to manage or that
people have to manage we have these
overwhelming plates of responsibility
and the only way to recognize the thing
that we need to put our focus and effort
into is learning how to detach from our
emotion because our emotions pull us in
and suck us into the chaos of all these
things that are happening and when we're
in that place we can't see the truth of
what needs to get done so we have to
learn how to manage our emotions so that
we can take that step back and detach
and recognize okay this thing right here
is going to have the biggest impact on
the mission and then focus of effort on
executing on that task we're not
naturally good multitask
multitaskers as people like to think
they are and so we have to be able to
detach long enough and then Focus effort
on executing on that thing before we
move on to the next
people ask about what's the difference
can you utilize these principles when
you're leading your family and I'm like
yes you can and they say is there any
differences and I say
there actually is and the big difference
is that when you're dealing with your
family
you're gonna be much more emotional and
it's going to take extra effort and
extra discipline to be able to detach
and not get emotional
like that's what it's going to take
that's the biggest difference there's a
little other little subtleties but
essentially the principles are the same
the biggest difference is when you're K
you know if Jamie's working for me and
she does something really stupid and
she's getting us in legal trouble I can
be like hey Jamie you're fired like okay
you know good luck carry on
when your kid does something stupid
you're like oh you can't fire your kids
you're stuck with them you can't fire
your spouse you're stuck with them so
you
you get more emotional because what are
you doing and you plus you care about
your kids so much you're like wait if
you don't if you're doing that thing
right now that's gonna that's gonna put
you on a bad course and you get
emotional and then when you get
emotionally make that bad decisions so
think about that
when you're dealing with the people that
are closest to you those are the people
that make you the most emotional
people that you don't care about it's
easy to make that's what's what you you
type a leadership question in a chat GPT
it's gonna give you a good answer
because it has no emotions it's just
like oh the person has been unproductive
for three months they should be fired
boom done okay cool we'll execute on
that uh but if you take a human being
you're like oh this person has been
unproductive for three months but guess
what what's going on in their personal
life
what oh they've got a their mom's sick
they've got to go to the hospital every
day while their mom's going through
chemo oh you're just gonna fire them
because they've been unproductive
although How's that gonna work out what
kind of human being are you so
think about that there's a little bit of
emotions involved with the stuff I
always say detached from your emotions
but you're not
decoupling from your emotions yeah
emotions have to be part of the calculus
they have to be part of the calculus
even with your team you know you have to
realize oh if I we just got done with
the muster and all of a sudden we get
tasked with some big project and Jamie
hasn't had one day off
and I go hey Jamie we've got this
project due tomorrow I gotta recognize
that she's gonna be mad at me
and I need to put that into calculus I
need to say hey Jamie look I know you're
going to be mad because you just got
back off this trip and I know you got
some things that you can do with your
kids we got this project due
if you can help me with this
next weekend is going to be a five day
weekend can you work with me and you're
like I got you
our our emotions typically help us
identify that there's a problem our
emotions are really important to helping
us recognize okay this is a priority
this is a major deal but we don't make
good decisions when we're emotional so
to your point you can't decouple the
emotions they typically are an indicator
that hey there's a problem here we need
to solve but we have to be detached
enough to be able to see how we can
actually solve this problem and we can't
do that when we're caught up in the
emotional state
yeah
um how about that decentralized command
I think you're uh you've gotten to
you've gotten to see decentralized
command in this full force they learn
from the best yeah Empower other people
to lead Empower your team to lead to
step up and take things on to solve
problems give them as much
ownership in the projects and plans as
you possibly can and that what's really
difficult about that is Letting Go at
least for me it's letting go like I want
to be in all involved in all those
things especially like you use the
mustard as an example the first time I
went to the muster and I wasn't doing
all the things I had done the muster
previous like you start to get the sense
of like well wait what am I here for
anymore and that that's an ego play but
the more that I've let go the more that
I recognize I get to see other people
step up into roles and take on
responsibility and execute and see them
Thrive that that just is way more
rewarding than me stepping in and
solving the problem and being the one to
save the day and do this awesome thing
that it's about the team and I get to
see them just feel valued and contribute
to the mission and that is so much more
uh powerful than anything else I could
offer them so giving them as much
responsibilities as I possibly can and
empowering them to make decisions and
solve problems and get things done
uh I have an app on my phone that
reports
when uh no it starts on an app it's a
email it's like an automatic email that
reports expenditures
from my bank which is our bank which is
and so this is my this is my I guess my
evidence of decentralized command I'll
just be like whatever on a trip or
something I'll pick up my phone I'll
look at it and they'll be like uh you
just you just wired 842 000 to this
account and I'm always like no okay cool
and uh what is I think have I upped your
limit your spending limit to a million
dollars yeah yep you told me I have I
have leeway to spend up to a million
dollars before I have to get permission
and I think in the earlier days I was
calling you for like 100 expenditures
I'm like hey I gotta buy this thing it's
a hundred bucks and now I've got up to a
million dollars so yeah right if you
need to spend more if you need to spend
more than a million dollars
can you let me know what that's about
just you know I just gotta know about
that one I think it was like six months
ago it was 7.50 so I'm really like I'm
really getting there now we're at a
million yeah but that's you know like
you said in the beginning
I'm watching like hold on what did she
spend 140 on you know what I mean what
are you doing and you're like well I had
to print out you know copies of the book
for example okay
okay so she's actually got good judgment
oh hey there's a 1200 charge on here
what's this for oh we had to get this
thing for the client otherwise oh okay
so then it's like over time I'm looking
at your judgment and by the way when
you're doing that I'm not like what the
hell did you spend that money or maybe
like hey hey what's this expense for and
so then you realize I'm not jumping down
your throat so you're starting to trust
that I'm going to listen to what you
have to say and before you know it I got
Jamie Cochran wiring money 890
000 to some random place I'm going what
is it not I actually don't even ask
anymore well there's a triple effect
because you implemented that with me and
over time I got a little more
comfortable being able to do those
things and make those decisions and now
I see it with Jen and the real trick is
just put something in your team that you
know is gonna I mean Jen stress is over
ten dollars like she can get a deal and
say 50 cents on like a product that
we're buying in bulk and she's like
stoked so she's such a good Steward of
our money that she has almost unlimited
leeway too because I know she's not
going to be out there making crazy
decisions and you figured out early on
that I wasn't gonna make crazy decisions
and I was actually very conscient
conscientious about what we were
spending and on what you know what it
was and how much we were spending
um that you gave me a lot of freedom in
the early days yeah you got to get
comfortable with some level of risk I
mean I'm sure sometime in the next year
somebody's gonna buy something and I'm
gonna be like did we really need to buy
I'm sure like there's somebody's gonna
spend three thousand dollars on
something and you've got to be
comfortable with that level of risk and
here's why I'm okay with it if I wasn't
okay with hey someone made it you know
someone bought a 2 800 meal with a
client that you know okay cool there's
that's going to happen this is going to
happen and the thing is if I was
paranoid about that we would literally
just not do anything we would just not
do anything because can you imagine if
you were sending me approvals every time
we spent more than a thousand dollars oh
my gosh we'd never get anything done
nothing would happen and so it's so but
you the financial
examples really clear but it's not just
the financial example it's like
everything that we're doing there's
there's there's decisions that are being
made there's things that are being
executed that they need to be executed
they need to be executed quickly and if
I was trying to micromanage things it
just it just would absolutely never work
we wouldn't be able to do anything we
wouldn't be able to advance not to
mention I mean you take that's Echelon
front you throw Jocko fuel you throw
origin on that you throw Jocko podcast
you throw Jocko publishing like there's
a lot of things that are a lot of
decisions that are being made that are
being made at the level at the point of
friction which is awesome which is which
is how things which is when people ask
me like how do you do all these things
I'm like oh I do all these things cover
Move simple prioritize actually
decentralized command that's what I do
that's how that's how I make it happen
that's how my team makes it happen
because we're not going to sit here and
micromanage so those things again can
you give decentralized command when you
first meet someone and you've never
worked with them before and you don't
understand their judgment you don't
understand how their mind works that can
be a challenge but once you understand
how their mind works once you build up
that trust you can move forward and then
once you establish culture inside of an
organization
then decentralized command can really be
can really be utilized and the again
using the mustard as an example
the first or whatever by the time we
were like the fourth or fifth muster
everything was now maybe there's the six
muster or seventh muster everything was
now just like super smooth and super
squared away and you know we would get
our feedback from the from the uh
attendees and they'd be like this is the
the most well-run event I've ever been
to and what's cool about that is I never
like sat you and Jen and your team down
and said like this needs to be the most
well-run event anyone's ever been to I
didn't tell you that you already knew
your team already knew so they knew on
the front lines when someone says to one
of the one of the front line people like
hey I'm supposed to be checking in my
hotel and my luggage is in the wrong
area uh what can I can you guys help me
their attitude isn't like well no that's
your luggage no their attitude's like oh
we want this to be the best thing hey
hold on a second we've got a driver they
can drive you out to the airport we can
get that luggage picked up do you want
to go with so that's the attitude and
when everyone understands what the
culture is
everyone understands what the mission is
then decentralized command just works
yep you said once that an executive team
uh meeting you said I can only do the
things that only I can do and what you
were saying basically is like you have a
lot of things you're managing I mean the
things on your plate are crazy and you
just mentioned some of those things and
so it was really this uh permission to
the rest of us like go do everything
else that you guys can answer and do and
accomplish go do it and come to me for
the things that only I can do and there
are certain things that only you can do
as the CEO of our company but everything
else you give us complete trust and
authority to go make those decisions and
that trust once again is so valuable to
everyone on the team that when we go to
a muster you never had to say what the
standard was because you set the
standard in the way that you operated
and manage this company that we all felt
this
Instinct of we have to this has to be
the best thing ever because I don't want
to let Jack go down I don't want to do a
disservice to this message that is a
life changer a game changer so it
started with the precedent you set and
the example that you set and then you
just gave up the reins and let us run
with it and we felt that sense of I have
to do this right because I was I was
entrusted in this
we talk about ego a lot and again the
reason we have to talk about ego a lot
is because that's a human instinct that
people have their instinct is to get to
believe their own hype that's what our
instinct is and especially when you're
successful
you think well you're damn right I'm
successful I I should be I'm pretty
awesome and then the next thing you know
you're believing your own hype and
that's a problem you have considering
you know your street a student gymnast
class president were you class president
uh I was in yes I was class president I
wasn't uh the like for the whole school
okay so you but you know you've been in
like you've been doing really well
when you came on board when you came on
board
you didn't know we were going to be
talking about ego but you had the
instinct to be humble enough to be like
okay I can do this job oh you want me to
answer the phone you want me to book
your your flight life okay I'll do it
right you you were humble enough to say
that where did you pick up that sense of
humility and how has your how has your
perspective of ego become clarified
while you've been a national front
yeah listen I am actually a very
competitive person and I definitely have
an ego a hundred percent it exists I
mean that's the only reason like why I
ever wanted to do all the stuff I wanted
to do because there was this ego sense
of like yes I can do it all and I can be
good at it all
um but uh but I also had incredible
examples in my life of humility my mom
and dad once again set this heavy tone
of like hey work ethic and honesty and
they were some of the most humble uh
people if not the most humble people
I've been around and they they had very
different life than I did they had a
difficult life growing up my mom ran
away when she was like 15. she put
herself in foster care my dad was poor
um and just really struggled and so they
propagated that story with our family a
lot and I understood where they came
from and that was not my experience at
all if anything kind of the world
revolved around me as a young kid
um but over time because of that example
I recognized that the ego pushes you to
want to win and want to succeed and that
definitely exists in me but if I wanted
to be successful I had to get really
good at managing and subordinating my
ego because I learned very early on that
that wasn't going to help me build
relationships and help me along the path
of what I wanted to accomplish
uh I'm a little bit
surprised why because you you're like
you're growing up right and you were
like the star of this and the leader of
that and the captain of this and your
the world revolved around you the way
your parents treated you like everything
that you've that you experienced I've
known a lot of people that grew up like
that and they are not humble
I'm just telling you like a lot of
people that grow up like that they're
not humble they think they're the center
of the world from the time they're born
and it really hurts them later on in
life but for some reason you were able
to identify that
sense of humility which is you're very I
don't know if you're lucky or what maybe
like you said I guess you the way your
parents instilled that in you
um but yeah there's plenty of people
that
are the star of this the captain of that
uh you know this the seals is filled
with guys like this right they were the
captain under this they were the villain
they were the quarterback here and they
were the they were did all these things
and they were just winning and when they
win they just think oh I obviously
deserve to be worshiped so well let's go
ahead and proceed to worship me
everybody and it hurts you know and
there's people like this in the
certainly in the business world as well
like you you know you Rose up through
the ranks in your company well why did
you get promoted because I'm awesome oh
why'd you get selected as the as the
chief operating Cosmos why'd you get
such as a CEO cause I'm awesome well you
know why'd you get these investors I got
these investors because I'm awesome
and so that can snowball and get out of
control obviously so that lesson that
your parents taught you I'm I guess it's
your parents
I think it is a combination of the
example that I had but also like I I had
all those things and then I moved to LA
and very quickly was kind of reminded as
a very young girl that I wasn't nearly
as good as I thought I was like I moved
you know little fish now in a big pond
and I was like oh I'm not the best
singer I'm not the best at this I'm not
the better best at this and I just
started a little bit of failure you know
and and recognizing okay I had a lot of
really cool things growing up and I was
really good in a lot of things I wasn't
the greatest I wasn't the best at
anything
um but I I think it was the combination
of my parents example and then getting a
phase of my life where I really started
to recognize like you know what I am not
nearly as good as I thought I was and
that set me up for Success when I
started to take on other opportunities
and and grow in my life because I
started being willing to accept that and
it's okay I don't have to be the best I
just have to work hard I just have to
perform and if I do that I can
accomplish anything that I actually want
to try to do and every time I just
focused on the work and the work ethic
component that my parents taught me I
succeeded and things happened for me
did you identify that when you were
reading extreme ownership for the first
time and you see like a chapter about
ego where you like oh I relate to this
yes I remember reading it for the first
time and just that first chapter of
extreme ownership just blowing my mind
like okay my parents always really
taught me about honesty but I hadn't
really ever thought about it in the way
of me making decisions or taking
ownership like that's that's a component
of honesty being honest with yourself to
say hey I screwed this up and as I did
that I started to realize that hey
that's a big ego hit to say this this is
my fault or I have to take ownership of
this but the more that I started to dip
my foot in that pool the more I started
to realize that it actually was an ego
boost because I started to feel a little
a lot more confident to say yeah no I
screwed that up yeah let me take on
ownership of that to the point now where
there's no ego involved I'll take
ownership all day long if anything it's
like you don't want to take ownership
I'll take it give it to me I'll take it
all day long because I know that if I do
that I can solve the problem and so the
ego component which still exists I still
want to win I still am very competitive
I am capable now of subordinating that
ego enough to recognize that the ego
will get in the way of actually
accomplishing the mission and I care
more about the mission than my own sense
of self
yeah it's a wild thing to say that
there's people that will literally
their ego will kill them like they will
make decisions and they won't want to
back down from their decision and they
will like in combat get people killed or
get themselves killed because they
didn't want to subordinate their ego and
it's crazy so if that can happen in
combat
it can happen anywhere it can certainly
happen in your finance company or your
Manufacturing Company these things
happen gotta watch out for that now
on the academy that was a while ago you
and I were having a conversation and it
was
I think you were trying to explain to me
that
from a from a female perspective
this stuff doesn't always look the same
and you and I I think I made did I make
you we didn't agree at first
no it was actually at A muster and we
were having some conversation and I
think I brought up like hey maybe we
should do like a women's like breakout
session at the muster or we could do
something because I was looking at the
the stats for the muster and we were
about like six seven eight percent women
and I was like okay there's a big
disparity here what if we added a
component to the event that was like
women only like a panel or something and
we got into this conversation and you
kept saying like no it's all the same
it's the same and in the moment I wasn't
hearing exactly what you were saying and
so I went back to my room and I remember
feeling frustrated because I was like it
was the first time I felt this
disconnect of like I don't think I agree
with Jocko like he doesn't get it he
doesn't understand this is different for
women he doesn't understand that I am
carrying almost the full mental load of
like managing our household I'm managing
groceries and dinner and taking kids to
school and doctor's appointments and
dentists and I'm also managing Echelon
front and he has no idea what that's
actually like and so I remember feeling
a little bit of like initial resentment
of like it's easy for you to just say
it's the same and then we went the next
day to the muster and I'm listening and
taking notes and you're talking about
the principles and it hit me and I
realized what you were saying was not
that my experience is different is you
know you were you were weren't saying
that my experience wasn't different than
yours you were simply saying that the
way that you saw those problems was the
same you have to apply the principles of
extreme ownership and that kind of
opened my mind to okay he's right my
experience might be different my
experience uh may be more challenging or
and sometimes feel maybe unfair but the
way that I solve those problems it is
the exact same that we would teach
anyone and so we started thinking about
okay how do we how do we get women more
on board with being open to this content
because I think there was some barrier
with the combat military component there
was the barrier was my face yeah and
they just you know we weren't seeing a
lot of women I mean and the women women
who were a part of this movement were
some of the coolest women I had ever met
like they were in the game and so we
needed to find a way to open the door to
for women to understand that this
content was absolutely for them and that
there was some really cool principles
out there that could help them solve the
problems that they were dealing with
yeah and so I think what cracked opened
my mind because I was still you know you
said well maybe we should do a breakout
for women and I was totally against that
because we're at a event together like
I'm not breaking out People based on
anything like your people we're all
people but what kind of cracked my mind
open a little bit to become open to the
idea of like you eventually want to do
an online thing called the women's
assembly and what kind of cracked my
mind opens was Jiu Jitsu because in jiu
jitsu
if you show up like at a lot of schools
a lot of academies they have women's
only Jiu Jitsu classes and usually what
those women's only Jiu Jitsu classes are
is a way for women to get into Jiu Jitsu
so that they understand it and once they
understand Jiu Jitsu they're just
training in the regular classes most of
the time most women make that transition
to where they're just training red
classes some of them don't but most of
them do and so I started to recognize oh
what Jamie wants to do is do a women's
Jiu Jitsu class for leadership where
people go and they they're comfortable
and they look there's not too many women
that look at my head and say oh yeah I
identify with that or I could relate to
that but they look at you and they think
oh yeah this is a woman she's a mom
she's in business she's got a lot of
things going on I can relate to that so
just like the Jiu Jitsu idea of a
women's only class that's the way I
looked at in my head I was like okay you
want to do something for women that's
going to make sure make them
feel comfortable coming into the Jiu
Jitsu Academy feel comfortable coming
into the extreme ownership Academy
okay let's go for it and then eventually
and now you've got a Women's Summit
coming we do so hey look you've got
women comfortable
from a online with the with the assembly
that you're doing but now you're doing a
women's summer tell me about that
so we started the live monthly free
sessions for the women's assembly two
and a half years ago and we just thought
you know we'll throw it out there and
see if we can get some people enjoying
and that Community started to grow and
we had like 7 000 people that are a part
of that assembly committee we've done
free sessions every month for the last
two and a half years and we started to
see the impact of the musters because we
went from eight percent to 12 to 15 to
the last semester where we had 22 women
so we started to see the adjustments
that we made pay off in like more women
coming to events and recognizing that
this content was for them and then as a
part of that we started to get sort of a
call to action or a request of hey we'd
like to do an all women's event there's
also a lot of men in our Network that
are like Hey how do I introduce this to
my daughter or wife coming from me it's
not a great thing when you're like hey
you should really read this book on
taking ownership and so the women's
assembly is
written by two neanderthals and it's
been a really cool way to kind of
introduce that in a more subtle way and
so we started thinking about doing this
live event with women who want to come
learn about leadership in business and
life and as a part of that we're going
to obviously teach the principles of
extreme ownership but we're also going
to bring in some women who have
interesting stories interesting
perspectives to share just some things
that are more relevant to women in
leadership
when does it take place September 14th
through 16th in Phoenix in Phoenix
Arizona yep
and it's who is it uh who's like give me
example of are you gonna go over the
fundamental principles that we talk
about do you have anyone else going to
speak yep so myself and Corey Mize and
Meg Miller from the echelon front team
we all are the The Women Leadership
instructors at Echelon front so we are
going to focus on introducing and
talking through just like you would get
at the muster the core of our content
the foundations of extreme ownership in
these principles and then inserted
throughout the session we have some cool
guests coming to share in their unique
perspectives a lot of which are very
closely tied to what we teach as well so
Ryan mannion who's been on this podcast
before she's going to come and give a a
keynote Debbie Lee Mama Lee is coming to
talk um and then we've got this
wonderful speaker Latonya Sumpter who
has now been on the women's assembly
free sessions twice and just has this
incredibly charismatic personality and
people are drawn to and she actually
brought her back from request so we're
bringing in a couple different people
we're bringing in a panel of echelon
front wives so we've got Helen willink
locked in to do this which I thought was
going to be I don't know how you pulled
that off honestly to her credit she was
like yes she didn't even fight me on it
I thought I was gonna have to really go
to bat for this but Helen and myself and
Iris Gardner who's amazing and then
Amanda Danelle and hopefully Cody's wife
page we're going to do a panel on sort
of the military wives perspective as
like the wives of echelon front all of
all of whom have been the on the home
front side of the combat that you guys
were serving and just have a unique
perspective to answer questions and help
women understand how to cultivate some
of that emotional Independence and talk
through these leadership principles from
our perspective both in the military and
now at Echelon front
I don't know how you got my wife to say
yes
dude I Was preparing for like this
indirect approach I had like the script
in mind and I called her and I like laid
it out I'm like hey just hear me out and
I go through the plan and she was in her
lovely sweet voice was like yes
I would do that and I think she's she
would never come on here she's made that
very clear like I will not come on this
podcast I asked her I said listen if I
write down questions and you write
answers and I'll read them on the
podcast you don't have to come on would
you do that she's like no
uh there's like what else can I do right
there's nothing else I can do and so
yeah I was pretty surprised that she
because she's very uh private person and
she doesn't like any Limelight and she
doesn't like to
you know do this kind of thing so
yeah good job but people want to hear
from her I know this is yourself yeah
and you're such a unique being that
people are like what is his wife like
which I can attest she is I think one of
the greatest people I know she's one of
the kindest people that I know for sure
and she's a total badass and you
wouldn't know it because she's so humble
and so sweet but uh I asked her to come
and she agreed and maybe it was the fact
that it was multiple people on stage she
wasn't going to be by herself and we're
just answering questions and I think she
loved the mission of helping women
be successful in their lives and she had
a perspective to offer so she she said
yes yeah so that's cool too there's a
reason to come just for that yeah for
sure
but uh yeah you know we also have three
daughters two of which are adult
daughters so she probably can connect to
to wanting to help out you know
um young ladies and with their as they
go through whatever they're going
through and and moms you know I mean so
I think it's gonna be awesome
I think everyone who has agreed to
participate so far and we we have more
surprises coming but a lot of that was
they loved the mission they were like oh
I get to go speak to a group of women
who are looking for answers to solve
problems in their lives in business and
in life and I have an opportunity to not
only teach and hopefully Inspire them
but be inspired by the atmosphere of
this group of people coming together
rallied around this mission of extreme
ownership so I am so excited I think
it's awesome too the the fact that
extreme ownership is clearly you know
meant initially for people that are in a
leadership position basically in the
workplace that's basically what it's for
but dang if it doesn't apply to
everything in every aspect of your life
and the way you're operating and
interacting with your family for sure
the way you're interacting with your
community for sure the amount of people
that have
talk to us talk to me talk to you and
explain how they implemented extreme
ownership
with their husband with their wife with
their kids in it it's a game changer you
wrote a book that was based on helping I
mean one
section in each chapter is titled
application of business but I learned
really early on and it was something you
said to me because I was dealing with
you know a phase my oldest was in a
phase and I was struggling with that and
I was talking to you about just some
frustrations and you were like hey these
same principles apply and I reread the
book and when I got to application of
business I just simply was like
application to home and I started to
recognize that this book was written for
businesses but it's even more important
at home and we see people crushing it in
their business taking these principles
applying it having so much success and
yet they get home and they they hit
these barriers they hit these walls
because as you said earlier your
emotions and your ego is so much more
involved that it's more difficult but
the payoff at home is even greater than
what you could get at home it worked and
I've seen that with my kids that when I
do the right things when I apply these
principles I see them model that
behavior back and there's no greater
gift I could give my kids then teaching
them and helping them understand this
idea of ownership and this recognition
that I can own all the problems that I'm
facing and I can take ownership of
solving those problems no greater gift
yeah when they follow that example it's
incredible I this is a little bit
tangential but it's a little bit on
point too I walked up to my garage gym
the other day and I walked in there and
my 13 year old daughter
she's in there listening to Led Zeppelin
and doing squats
you know what I mean bruh amazing you
know what I mean sure are we in the game
you know does that you think that I
didn't like get a tear in my
non-shooting eye when that happened I
was like yep
[Music]
you having a good workout
she's like yeah just give me a high five
she's looking jacked you see what I'm
saying so yeah that the other thing I I
said this uh a while ago I don't know
what event we did but we went to a jiu
jitsu Place afterward and I said
hey
these principles from Jiu Jitsu apply to
your life
and I said and unfortunately some people
don't take the principles from Jiu Jitsu
and apply them to their life and there's
black belts out there that are black
belts on the mats and they're white
belts in life and they make mistakes
that you shouldn't make and it's the
same thing what you just said like
there's business people that are doing a
great job with their team they're doing
a great job with their business they're
doing a great job with their clients
from applying these principles and then
they don't apply them with their wife
they don't apply them with their kids
and it just goes it's terrible to watch
it's absolutely terrible to watch and
it's it sounds callous
it sounds callous to say well you know
you if you if you treat your kid like
your employee then that's what you
should be doing well actually if you
talk if you listen to us on how we
actually say you should treat your
employee which is you should respect
them you should listen to them you
should explain the why you should you
should allow them to influence like all
those things that we talk about if you
treat your kid like that they're gonna
be stoked they're going to be stoked and
so will the people that work for you and
by the way this is another thing that's
I I have to explain to people now is
like they'll think there's a difference
between the way I treat my boss and the
way I treat my peer and the way I treat
my subordinate that I'm oh well if it's
your boss you gotta do you treat them
this way now listen we talked about
communication I might communicate
but the way I treat them with respect
the way I listen to them
the way I care about them up down across
the chain of command it's the same
and so when you take those principles
and you apply them to your children and
you apply them to your spouse like what
does it make sense to treat your
children the same way as you treat your
spouse actually
listen to your spouse listen to your
kids allow your spouse to influence you
allow your kids to influence you treat
your spouse with respect treat your kids
with respect now listen if they're four
years old and they're doing something
stupid you can't let them play in the
street I get it
I get it
and by the way there's some
there's some gambles you can take there
there's some risk you can allow for
life's got a good story his daughter
didn't want to wear flip-flops across
the cactus covered grass or whatever and
she's you know he says hey put your
flip-flops on I don't want to
and he was like okay she goes running
across the grass boom she got her feet
fill a cactus or whatever they got down
there in Tejas but you know he she's
gonna get a lesson learned and
he's listening to what she has to say
and so when he listens she's going to
listen more so yeah these things do work
up down across the chain of Commander at
work up down across the chain of command
on your pickup basketball team and up
down across the chain of command into
your house
so utilize them they're there we are
giving these away
we are giving these away they giving by
the book for 20 bucks
I can get all the books for 50 bucks
probably you can listen to podcasters
free you can go to the women's Assembly
online it's free
you can go to the First Responders
online it's free like you can listen
this podcast it's free there's all kinds
of we're trying to give this away
I remember it was probably
second or third podcast that Echo and I
were recording and I had some nugget
some Golden Nugget of leadership and I
was thinking to myself like oh should I
share this right now because like we
have Echelon front and Echelon front
people pay money to to learn the stuff
and if I'm just giving away
and I made a Consciousness and I was I
said to myself you know what the best
thing I can do is try and get this
information to as many people as
possible that's the best thing to do and
that's what I'm gonna do and I haven't
held back anything obviously there's
hundreds and hundreds of hours of this
stuff but
to get this information out there that's
the goal and and so we're giving it away
the reason we're giving away is because
we know it's going to make people's
lives better and you get to you get
you're on the receiving end of a lot of
the people that message us about
how it's helped them kids adults moms
dads CEOs Frontline workers it's
everybody
yeah you've said this before and it's my
one of my favorite quotes of yours but
if you do the right things for the right
reasons you will win in the end and I
think you've always kind of taken that
stance of I'm going to give this stuff
out because our goal and our mission is
to help as many people as possible
understand these principles learn how to
apply it in their lives so that they can
see the impact but not just in their own
lives and the lives of the people around
them and one of my favorite things about
what I get to do here especially earlier
on is I was always the first point of
contact when people would reach out and
say let me share with you how these
principles have changed my life which we
have heard that I couldn't even count
the number of times someone has said
changed my life and it was really them
recognizing that they could take
ownership of their situation whether it
was their health or their addiction or
their family or their work or whatever
it was that they were trying to solve
people started coming out and sharing
these stories and we realized early on
okay we have to start using that
internally to help propagate our story
and we can give this out for free and
it's not going to impact our ability to
grow and and build a business because we
have people here we have to take care of
that if anything it Amplified that
effort because we had people out there
sharing in their message of hey I
implemented ownership in my life and
here's the outcome of what happens and
it changed my life it changed my life
and so like I resonated with that when I
started getting this feedback I'm like
yes I see that you're totally right it's
a game changer so
um you know we've said it before but
when you start taking ownership and you
really get to the point where ownership
is your instinct
everything in your life gets better
every single thing and maybe not easier
definitely not easier I think ownership
is hard in a lot of ways much more
difficult than just taking the easy out
of casting you know letting someone else
be the problem but it gets better
because you can actually solve it it's
harder at first and then over time it
gets easier and easier and easier and
there's people that talk to us that say
that these principles change their lives
and there's also people that talk to us
that say these principles save their
lives I mean I can't tell you how many
people have told me that
what we do save their lives and what I
tell them every time which is the truth
we didn't save your life I didn't save
your life the book didn't save your life
the podcast that you did it you you
saved your life you changed your life
you took this information and applied it
that's you we appreciate the compliment
but
that's what it takes it is on you you
can read this material you can study
this material you can listen this
material you have to take action with
this material otherwise if things aren't
going to change
so
keep that in mind that is one of the
keys
that is one of the keys to moving
forward
some other keys to moving forward I
think for you
um you from a from like a health
perspective
you kind of get after it don't you
I try I mean you run marathons right
yeah you got like a crossfit gym in your
house yeah
um you do Jiu Jitsu yeah
can I get a hell yeah please
you're a blue belt jiu jitsu
reluctant Bluebell but yes you don't get
a blue belt unless you're a blue film I
know I know I've got to put my faith and
trust in our instructor but I still feel
every day that I have to earn that I
have not in my mind earned that blue
belt
but don't you do well competitively
against other blue belts
things that I
but it's and it's the only thing in my
life that's really just for me like I
get to show up and I get a moment where
my brain turns off and I get to just
focus on what's Happening and like I
need to try to survive this and I love
it so much but my journey in Jiu Jitsu
is very much like a I wouldn't even call
it a roller coaster because I'm not like
it's like I'm I'm on the bus and I'm
going and it's going great and then I
get off the bus and I wait and I go like
three four months sometimes before I get
back into the gym because if there's one
thing when I have you know implementing
prioritize and execute if there's one
thing that I need to get off my plate in
order to focus on Echelon front my
family which are the two main priorities
it's the easiest thing to put on the
back burner and then what happens is I
look at the week and I'm like well I can
only train once this week and then I
convince myself that like is it really
worth it to go the one time and then all
of a sudden it's been three weeks and
now I'm dealing with like kind of the
ego of like I have to walk back in the
gym and tell Gustavo like hey I'm back
um so I do that a lot I kind of go in
and out and so when I got my blue belt I
was like I really feel like I need to be
a lot more consistent before you can
pass this off to me
um and so he did the right thing though
because it's it's fueled the sense of
like all right now I gotta earn it like
if he's gonna give this to me I want to
I don't want to let him down I've got to
actually show up and earn it so it might
be an ebb and flow it might be a long
journey before I get to you know where I
don't even I don't even know black
belt's in like my purview like it'll be
a long journey as a blue belt and it may
take me a while to get there but it's
just a matter of just showing up to your
point earlier and just like walking
through the door and every time I do it
after a stint of being out I like walk
back in I'm like what am I doing like I
miss this so much it is a it it's such
an amazing sport every woman should go
try a jiu jitsu class hell you yeah they
should yeah I was chuckling the other
day because I got a text at 10 o'clock
at night that said like hey Chuck I was
just at this Jiu Jitsu class and the
instructor said that if there's if
they're just totally you're in a bat
really bad situation what I do is
survive what was it survive and then
stabilized stabilize
oh okay yeah so
survive
I was struggling okay I was struggling
with a particular position and I was it
was five minute rounds just back to back
to back and I was getting my ass handed
to me and I was like all right so I went
over to one of the black belts Randy and
I was like hey I'm really struggling on
this position what advice can you give
me and he gave me something like
tactical to do and then he was like
listen I think about Jiu Jitsu as
survive defend advance and you're
constantly going back and forth in those
things so you might survive and then you
get a chance to now defend the move and
then something happens and they make a
shift and you have to go back to
survival and I started thinking about it
as just life like that's how we manage
sometimes chaotic things are happening
and your first instinct is you just have
to survive this then you get to a safe
space now you can start to defend and
make a position and start you know in
Jiu Jitsu shrimping out or doing little
movements to try to get yourself in a
better position and then once you've
defended properly you can now advance
and actually solve the problem and I
tried it in the next five minute round
and he was totally right like I just
kept thinking okay survive protect my
neck now got a fan Hands On The Hip
let's do this and now I've got to
advance I can actually sweep and get
into a better position so it was a it
just
prove the point that you've always made
that the lessons in Jiu Jitsu apply so
well in leadership it's so connected
when did you start training
um it's probably been is that where you
got to Virginia no I started in Seattle
at a women's it was a women's only see
we had to get you in the door yep and I
found a community there and just loved
it and then I started doing the co-ed
classes there and then I moved to
Virginia Beach and I called you and I
was like hey what gym should I go to and
you were like Gustavo machado's hands
down so I showed up there and I've been
training I mean it was covid so a little
bit of a weird time but I've been
training there for three years on and
off yeah well there you go awesome and
that's just a little message for
everybody
for everybody I think so even now
everyone at this table
if a little time goes by and you haven't
gotten on the mats of Justice no problem
we'll get back on the mass adjusters
right back on there yeah we all learned
that lesson we all learned that lesson
you got to take some licks I bet you the
ego
has them has a lot of victories in Jiu
Jitsu yeah you know the ego has defeated
more people in Jiu Jitsu than anybody
else more than Hicks and Gracie you know
what I'm saying I do know what you're
saying because the ego's like well if
you go in there today you know that guy
might be there and he might tap you out
because you haven't been trained like
that's that happens legitimately people
go people literally have that
conversation in their head and they go
I'm not gonna train today I'm just not
gonna go and then and then next week or
the next day you know what they're doing
I'm not gonna go today and it just
builds up you gotta just bite the bullet
man yeah the the most common I don't
know if this is what particularly what
you meant but let's say whether you get
a Blue Bell Pearl whatever your belt is
right you let's say you take a month off
or two months months off and then you're
like shoot if I go back tomorrow I'm
gonna be a step behind
and everyone's gonna know that I'm not
really that good of a blue belt and then
you're like so I just won't go then
another month pass now you're like even
one step in your mind mentally right
meanwhile everyone at class they don't
care yeah
in fact they're happy to see you to be
honest with you they're like oh you're
back okay you know whatever you want to
tap you out yeah but that's always the
case though that's the thing nothing
changes that doesn't yet nothing changed
there's a girl in my gym now and she
when we first started we were both white
belts at gustavo's and she was a beast
and I love training with her she's just
such a fun partner because she's tough
and she's hard but she's a good partner
and I started doing what I do which is
I'm in and out and she just stayed with
it and so I'm watching her on social all
the time she's competing now she's
dominating and she's just a force of
Nature and she has just been so
consistent in the last two and a half
years where I've been like heart going
hard for a month and then out for two
months and no one sees me and there it's
total ego because I like look at her and
I'm like man like we were at the same
level two years ago and now she she I
mean she's a purple belt and she could
just she she toys with me you know I'm
surviving the entire round but every
time I show up she is like hey girl
what's up like where you been like how
are you doing and she gives me you know
she's just so polite and it again it's
just like it brings me back to No One
Cares they're just glad you're here yeah
that's how egocentric we all are we all
think when we walk in the gym that
everyone's looking at us just like you
know you oh I'm gonna look stupid if I
do this it's like no I'm gonna look from
a leadership perspective like oh I'm
gonna look stupid if I ask a question or
if I admit that I don't know how to
conduct this project if I admit that
everyone's gonna think no people be like
oh yeah cool no big deal here you know
just welcome back yeah yeah welcome back
no big deal we move on and how many
marathons have you run have you just run
one no I did that's right yeah I really
I hate I hate running
evidently I hate running uh so no one
should be impressed with me my first my
first marathon you know Flynn did and he
didn't train I trained hard like
hardcore and we ran the Marine Corps
marathon and it was it was for team
Brendan so this is a year after he died
so I'm like all right I gotta like step
my game up and I train for this thing
and you know Flynn finishes and I think
he finished in like 4 10 or something
without without training at all and he
was like disappointed in himself and
he's like man this thing is humbling
like I had old people beating me I had
like women beating me and he's like
thinking he you know it was just a
humbling experience and I'm like hey I
just finished with the guy that juggled
the entire race like I don't want to
talk about humbling so
um I did that first marathon and it was
awful uh and then somehow I just kept
getting trapped um you know I met Jen
Tarantino she had never run a marathon
and and I was like well okay I guess we
could train for one and so we started
training for one and I ran another one
with her and then
I started getting my dad uh involved in
running which was just an incredible
journey because I I asked my dad to run
this like Tough Mudder and he's like
Jamie I haven't ran a mile in like 40
years and I was like yeah I was like um
I was like you could do it like we'll
just we'll run you know we'll start with
a mile and so I go and I pick him up and
he's wearing jeans
I was wearing jeans to this run hell
yeah and like he's running and my dad's
kind of tall and lanky and he's running
and I'm watching him from the side view
like oh my what is going on because he
you could tell he doesn't know how to
run like his it just was not a good
situation and we ran a mile he thought
he was gonna die
um and then I showed up two days later I
bought him like legitimate like pants
and a runny shirt and um we go and we
run another mile and then we run a mile
and a half and then two miles and we
just start building up and we do this
Tough Mudder which was 10 miles but
obstacles every half mile so you don't
have to run you know in entire in its
entirety and he finishes it and you
could see this sense of like total
accomplishment and so then I was like
hey what what if we did a half marathon
and so we did a half marathon and the
entire race he's like don't ask me to do
him full I'm not going to do a full and
then we finished the half and he's
watching the full marathoners come
across and he got that little like
so I waited a month just enough time to
forget how bad the half was and then we
started training for a fall so we did
our first full together then we did a
second one together and then he I moved
to Virginia Beach and he started
training with my niece his granddaughter
so he ended up running another marathon
with I ran that one but I only did the
half uh with them and my he ran another
marathon with my with my uh niece his
granddaughter
so with everything you've got going on
kids work running a company you still
make time to do Jiu Jitsu you make time
to stay in shape I think that's just
freaking such a mandatory thing to do
with life
you I get so much more accomplished if I
am taking care of myself and I figured
out a long time ago the best way for me
to be disciplined in taking care of
myself and doing those things is by
helping someone else along the way so
all of the running with my dad like I
would not I am not that disciplined to
get up and go train for that marathon on
my own but I was trying to help my dad
accomplish something and I was getting
time with my dad that you don't really
get as an adult I mean hours a week
running with him uh and then even with
Jen like when we started working out and
we've trained for our first marathon it
was helping her like she had never done
anything like that so I think I figured
out that in order for me to succeed in
my desire to want to continue to be
healthy and do these challenging things
I've got to be helping someone else
accomplish it because I'm way better
when it comes to helping someone else
than just trying to do it on my own and
when left to my own devices I'm actually
not that great so
so I I have to get creative and like
create these scenarios where I'm like
hey let's run a race and now I'm in
charge of helping this other person and
that becomes a motivator for me it's
interesting how it's so much harder to
let someone else down than it is to let
yourself down even like uh Jordan
Peterson has one of those one of his uh
rules is like treat yourself as if you
were someone that you were trying to
help yeah right it's that same thing
like you wouldn't not show up to run
with your dad but if it was just you man
you're in that rack Jamie Cochran I'm
like it's raining outside I think I'll
take the day off and my dad is one of
those he's the best training partner
because you give him a schedule of like
here's the things we're gonna run and
here's how many miles and what days and
he sticks to it he's Crossing every
single training run off that schedule so
you're not getting out of the seven mile
run or the nine mile run on a Saturday
because he's like what time are we
meeting we gotta cross this off so he's
the best training partner to have find
someone who's like sticks to the plan
sticking to the plan
um
where were you at does that get us up to
speed Jamie Crawford
to today to today are we there I think
we're there you think we're there Echo
Charles you got any questions yeah
I'll rewind a little bit back to when
you're in La he said the music industry
wasn't good for you for women for what
did you say for young women it is a
difficult environment to be in there's
just a lot of pressure there's a lot of
scrutiny there's a lot of self-doubt a
lot of insecurities that you're dealing
with
um and it's just you know women already
you know you have daughters you've
probably seen this and I've tried to
explain this to my husband but there
comes a point in I think I would dare to
say and I know we're not making
generalizations here but I would dare
say most women get to a point in their
life where the world has convinced them
they're not good enough they're not
pretty enough they're not smart enough
they're not skinny enough and they have
all these fears and insecurities and
they have to work through that and so
that environment amplifies that
significantly and so
um I just think it's you know I have a
daughter and I think about her and how
do I prepare her to the best of my
ability to manage what the world will
someday tell her and my husband
Flynn is always like no no that won't
happen with Charlie I'm like it will
happen with Charlie and we just need to
prepare her for that and I got into that
environment and realized very quickly
that that's where I kind of reconciled
with what the world was telling me and
that I needed to get out of that in
order to maintain my sense of security
and comfortability in who I was yeah
that makes sense yeah that goes into the
conversations we've had before about
ecosystems and you get into an ecosystem
where
it's just that's what you think the
world is and that's not oftentimes
that's not very healthy whether that
ecosystem is the music industry in LA or
whether that ecosystem is the dang ivy
league College in Boston or whether that
ecosystem is some business that you're
in or being in the military there's
people that you know they're in that
military ecosystem and they they're
stuck in it and they're doing things
that don't make sense in their life but
they're trying to preserve their their
status in that ecosystem and people that
applies to all of them music anything
they have you get in there and you're
you start judging yourself against this
world and you're doing things that
actually don't make sense for you as a
human being but you're trying to
maintain your status inside that
ecosystem and it's just absolutely
terrible and it's very difficult that's
what's that's what I find very
impressive about your story is a lot of
these things people don't realize like
what you just said you were in an
ecosystem that was not healthy and you
you as a 20 year old girl said oh I can
see that this ecosystem is bad I need to
get out of it that's a very challenging
thing to do that's a very challenging
thing to do most people they get in
those ecosystems they double triple and
quadruple down inside those ecosystems
that's what normally happens so another
great lesson for life is that's why we
talk about Detachment you got to detach
all the way outside of that ecosystem
and because that's what happens people
detach from where they're at but they're
still inside the ecosystem and they
think well uh I just need to do more I
need to do do this do this even harder
and it just doesn't work out so be
careful of that look around the world
look around the world and you no matter
where you are you're in some kind of
ecosystem
you're in Silicon Valley and you think
you need to be in the startup or you're
in the college and you think you need to
do the good uh
internship with the big tech company or
you're in the AAA baseball and you think
you need to like you can just pick the
the ecosystem and if you are if your
heart's not there and you're doing it
anyways that's where that's what hurts
some people that's what they're into
which I get you know I get it
but if your heart's not really there and
you're doing it for the wrong reasons
it's not going to work out good so watch
out for that anything else Echo Charles
no that's it I'll just say I think
that's what I learned when I was young
by doing so many different things one of
the benefits of not honing in on one
thing is I never got stuck in any of
those ecosystems I had exposure to
different people different perspectives
and going from sport to Sport and music
and plays and different I just had
exposure to so much more and I can
easily sit here at this table and say
like oh I I recognize this and I made a
choice but the reality is in the moment
that wasn't happening it wasn't as clear
I had a lot of people around me that I
could look to and say you know what I
what do I want for my life do I want
that or do I want that so I was lucky
because I was at least aware enough to
recognize that there were things that I
wanted and I I saw what those people
were doing and I was like all right I
need to go down that path to get to that
and so I never got stuck in that
ecosystem because of the people around
me but that's easy to do now looking
back through this lens of ownership of
the mistakes or the choices that I made
but in the moment those things were not
instinctual like it wasn't like I got
there and I was like I need to get out
of this like no I sat there for a while
and dabbles in that and then realized
looking up and out you know what I don't
actually want this this doesn't like
this isn't who I want to be so let me
let me look elsewhere and I think
growing up doing a million things I was
more comfortable saying let me pivot and
try something different yeah which this
was foreshadowing conversation I asked
you
three hours ago or whatever like wait a
second you were training gymnastics four
hours a day six days a week that's an
ecosystem and it's a strong ecosystem
and there's people in there that there
there's people in there if you if you
ask a 12 year old gymnast like what is
the ultimate thing to do in human life
they'd be like compete in the Olympics
and gymnastics and there's a whole pack
of them and so you at age whatever 13 14
looked around and said that's cool but I
actually want to do other things too
like that's that's an amazing uh ability
for you to have and it's a huge lesson
learned for for anybody that's listening
Jamie any closing thoughts
I just want to express in this moment
and opportunity of gratitude to you for
the opportunity to be here at us on
front what we get to do here is like
nothing I could have ever imagined and
the journey we just walked through I'm
always so uncomfortable talking about
myself I'd so much rather hone in on the
principles and what we teach in these
Leadership Lessons but the truth is the
reason I feel that way is because these
things have legitimately changed my
perspective and my ability to take on
problems and come up with Solutions so
if there's anyone out there that's you
know listening to the this podcast or
wanting to to understand these
principles stop hesitating stop making
those excuses and just start doing it
and you will see your life change ahead
of you as far as what you can handle and
what you can manage and what you can
solve
well I think what's awesome is you know
my mind being open to the idea that
the way you have a women's Jiu Jitsu
class you need to have a women's
assembly
and and I've also I have talked to you
about this look there's a 13 year old
boy right now and a 16 year old boy and
a 14 year old boy and they can look at
Uncle Jake way the warrior kid they can
look at me and be like oh yeah when I
grow up that's what I want to be like I
want to be like that guy he looks strong
he looks tough that's what I want to be
like
and there's a lot of examples like that
there's a lot of guys out there that
would that that you could take a 13 year
old kid and say hey you should you
should try and behave like that guy that
guy's setting a pretty good role model
you emulate that guy and I think for
girls and like I said I have three
daughters
I don't know
that there's that many out there I don't
know that there's that many legitimate
role models for young women for young
girls to look and say oh that seems like
a really good path that that individual
went down and I I talked to these I told
you that months ago I said you know I'm
looking at my daughters and I'm like who
who are they looking up to what are they
who are they seeing on well I see who
they see you see it on Instagram that's
where you see it you see it on on Tick
Tock you see it on Snapchat like that's
what they're getting inundated with and
I know that's not healthy and look
there's plenty of bad examples for young
boys as well but
I think for you for you to be an example
for I mean for anybody of any age but
also especially for a 13 year old girl
right now a 15 year old girl right now a
20 year old girl right now that's
looking around going hey why am I in
this ecosystem
do I want to be a part of this
what can I actually do what are my
limitations and I think you're living
proof
that there really are no limitations
that you can go out you can take
ownership of your life you can take
ownership of your world and you can make
things happen so thank you for sharing
all of that with us
thanks for sharing those lessons thanks
for also honestly uh and most maybe not
most important but thanks for your
service as a as a military spouse the
families don't get enough credit
I can guarantee you
that your husband who I know was less
worried when he was on deployment than
you were like the the families and the
spouses are the ones that have to worry
so thanks for your service there and
then at Echelon front
I don't know what the numbers are right
now but our growth has been phenomenal
and you are the person with the or in
your hand paddling and making this boat
move so thanks for everything you do uh
for us at Echelon front and the lives
that are impacted by by these principles
and that company so thank you well thank
you for setting
setting the tone
right on Echo Charles yes speaking of um
you know trying to set the tone trying
to live a good example
what do you think we should be doing
Jamie thinks we should be doing Jiu
Jitsu we're going to be doing Jiu Jitsu
well Jamie thinks we should be doing
kind of everything yeah
I respect it you know it's true actually
make a good point man because you don't
really think about that like that ease
of
like if you committed to and how you
said gymnastics right chocolate where
it's like okay if you're in gymnastics
you're like yeah I'm gonna go to the
Olympics or whatever and then you get
starts to get hard and be like man I'm
not even progressing as fast and all
this stuff and then you kind of consider
okay if I don't do this what am I going
to do and if the answer is kinda nothing
versus Jamie's over here well about you
know 900 999 other things it's easier to
kind of make that make an informed
decision you know on your next move bro
you want to talk about dream killer I
went and talked to
um eighth grade students the other day
and I would you know I was asking boys
well hey what do you want to do in your
crop 50 of them
I would say named some kind of
professional athlete football baseball
basketball whatever 50 yeah so I took
the first one second one by the fifth
one I was just turning into a not not
angry but reality check Jocko I'm like
what's your backup plan do you know what
percentage of people actually make it
into the NBA it's a tiny number and you
look like you're not going to be that
tall what's your backup plan I had to
and you know what the thing is no one's
telling these kids this yeah no one's
telling these kids this and by the way
how much basketball can you practice
tell me Echo Charles how much basketball
can you practice how many hours a day
can you practice I think he caps that
about at about 10 10 hours so you got 10
hours you're gonna sleep for eight yep
that's 18 hours you've got six hours
left over to figure out what your backup
plan is going to be so even if you
completely committed 10 hours a day to
making it in the NBA you can still have
six hours a day to figure out what your
backup plan is going to be that's what
I'm talking about
so you gotta have a backup plan you have
to have a backup you have to have a
backup because you don't know you do not
know what you want to be in eighth grade
I'm sorry like there's a very few people
like the Dave Burks of the world that's
like I'm gonna be a pilot and go be a
pilot most of us go the route that I did
where I'm like I know what I want to be
and then like very quickly was like
actually let me pivot and you have to
have a backup plan and and you're right
no one's talking to kids about that now
nowadays it's I realized that the kids
are they don't connect what's happening
right now to their future they don't can
make those connections if they're lucky
their parents are like hey get straight
A's you don't really know why but maybe
you're gonna get you know uh two dollars
for every a that you get and that ends
up being 10 bucks and so you can kind of
relate to that so you work hard most
kids aren't like oh I know what I'm
gonna do we get straight it's not gonna
be a good college it's gonna be in a
program I'm gonna get a doctorate in
this like that's not most kids and I get
it that there's some kids that are out
there that are like that cool they're
not going to have any issues unless they
over commit to an ecosystem that they
can't quite get into because there's
people that their goal in life is to get
into an Ivy League school and when they
don't get in because it's freaking
competitive they
don't know what to do they break down
they have problems but that's what we
have to do is you have to broaden your
mind you have to just well one of my
friends actually our friend Brian
sergeant
he his he asked his one of his kids
um well it sounds good like you need to
study hard you need to get good grades
and he's like why do I need to get
grades and good grades and he says well
what do you want to do and you get older
and his his kid says I don't know and he
said exactly
exactly and when you don't know and you
get bad grades you're just closing doors
you're just closing doors on yourself
you're closing doors on your
opportunities so when you can maintain
good grades you can try a bunch of
different sports you can behave well you
cannot get in trouble like those are the
things that are going to open the most
amount of doors for you that you can
capitalize on somewhere down the line
because as Jamie just pointed out you
don't know what you're gonna do what you
want to do when you're in sixth grade or
seventh grade or eighth grade or 12th
grade sometimes
or 24. yeah I mean we just talked to
another guy who was who's at West Point
in the engineering program and he's like
yeah a second year at West Point in the
engineering program I realized I don't
want to be an engineer like that's
that's crazy so there's a 20 year old
individual that's in a military academy
that is doesn't know what he wants to do
so keep your options open the way you
keep your options open is by working
hard
so make that happen difficult nowadays
because there's a trend now especially
with sports where like you're gonna get
your kid into the sport at three years
old and that's going to be your only
four focus and they're gonna go to the
competition and the travel team and
they're going to focus so much on that
one sport but what happens in high
school when they change their mind or as
an adult they get injured and they can't
do it or they don't make it and parents
put that on their kids and uh I learned
from my parents example that I'm gonna
let my kids they want to Nico decided
six months ago he wanted to try lacrosse
I was like sure and he started playing
the cross and he loves it cool cool
sounds good and he may decide he wants
to continue through high school or he
may decide he wants to change his mind
but just give him exposure to as much as
you can yeah it's going to open up their
adaptability as well and adaptability is
such a key component of survival in life
you know the animals that survive are
the ones that are most adaptable the
humans that do the best are the ones
that most of it adaptable that's what
makes Special Operations good so we're
good at adapting to the situation that's
on the ground so raise your kids so that
they're adoptable not so that they can
do one random thing like you know hit a
ball with a stick or do a double back
handspring which actually that has
completely legit it's a good thing to
know how to do but it also translates
really well to a bunch of different
things but backhand Springs yeah well I
mean it's just the athletic capability
the explosiveness the flexibility like
there's a lot of positive things that
come out of that and there's positive
things coming out of a hitting a ball
with a stick too right hand-eye
coordination but but let's not make that
the sole Focus as you just pointed out
let's not make that the sole Focus
any
.001 that they have the genetic
capability the timing the injury
prevention to have every star in the
galaxy line up that they can get to the
NBA the NFL or whatever so just be
careful
I'm my dream killing monologue is
complete yes sir
we are staying physically capable
that's what we're doing on all fronts
yes yeah you know um you know longevity
say capabilities say call that stuff
with that we do need fuel you need fuel
clean fuel you need Jaco fuel Jamie what
are you drinking right now chocolate
milk chocolate milk how tasty is that
tasty chocolate milk and orange go
that's a daily for me that's your daily
go-to when do you have them when do you
have a go
usually for me and I know this is way
late in the day for you it's usually
like one o'clock for me
news Academy
it's right it's right at the start yeah
yeah so it's like one or two o'clock
yeah yeah I like to have one around the
academy that's pretty normal for me or
like if I'm doing a presentation I like
to get that go together and I'll be
honest with you and I don't know if this
is cheating I don't know what the law is
about this but lately I've been having
to go on my way to jiu jitsu that's sort
of that's sort of my thing right now and
I sort of feel like it's
hyping me up in like a real kind of way
I've seen the videos lately you look
hyped up I'm hyped up and then when do
you have a mock in the morning or post
Jiu Jitsu post
s i don't eat breakfast very often so
Mulk is like a really quick easy way to
to get some fuel in the morning what I'm
stoked about Mulk is you can drink it on
an empty stomach and not like have your
stomach go into a rebellion which can
happen if you drink like milk regular
milk bro you might get a rebellion on
your hands you might get some some
reactions that you're not gonna like so
we got Mulk we got go we got chocolate
fuel chocolate fuel.com go check it out
yep
um for all elements of capability yeah
you run into a roadblock physically boom
Taco fuels there save the day got you
covered you can get this stuff at Wawa
bottom right because look where's some
pressure from the from the bottom right
means
is that the Wawa like placement now yeah
Wawas are big out where I am everyone's
complaining about it and I've asked
people I asked someone I'm like hey
where you know what's up with the Jocko
go and the guy at the front he's like
everyone keeps asking me that like he he
doesn't have an answer either but you
gotta find them they're hidden yeah
they're usually bottom right yeah the
answer is that some of the big uh
beverage Empires came in and and bought
our slots which look they're running a
business at Wawa good good for them
um but just know that your people are
out there and they want that go yes but
you put them in Harris Teeter so anyone
on the East Coast like now I don't have
to go to Wawa I don't have to deal with
Wawa anymore I can go to Harris Teeter
and get the get the whole the whole kit
so Harris Teeter Wawa if you can find a
vitamin shop GNC by the way GNC like
that's Nationwide vitamin shops
Nationwide military commissaries if
you're in the military Hannaford Dash
stores wake Fern ShopRite HEB and Tejas
you people in Tejas thank you
thank you I know it's life and JP for
sure they're going hot but there's no
way they could buy as much uh go and
Jocko fuel as heb's got and is getting
and is selling so everyone down in Texas
thank you for going getting after it
there at HEB we're in Myers we're in
Harris Teeters you just pointed out
Lifetime Fitness Shields just went to
Shields
Shields we went to Shields they got the
whole line at Scheels they're fired up
so
also if you've got a gym
if you've got a Jiu Jitsu Academy and
you want to have Jocko Fielder you got a
little CrossFit box you got some other
kind of Fitness scenario going on and
you want to sell this stuff go to
jfsales jacofuel.com and we'll give you
that wholesale account and I'll be
honest with you you know
you kind of become a little bit of a
crack dealer
I know it's illegal or not but you give
someone a can they're good they're back
tomorrow they're back there training
they're getting stronger they're getting
better it's helping your whole scenario
so yeah check it out jogofuel.com also
originusa.com so origin right all these
uh what jeans boots uh rash guards geez
all this stuff how is this helping
us houses helping America are you
talking about you want to improve the
national security for your country for
your children and your grandchildren is
that what you want to do sure you're
telling me that you want to actually
help us win globally against tyrannical
Empires is that what you're saying yeah
yeah get yourself a pair of jeans from
originusa.com because we're bringing a
manufacturing back to America right now
and the best hoodies on the market get
the best hoodies out there yeah this is
how good the hoodies are so I use uh so
I have the OG one you know the the
Heather like it's two holes for me like
pulling it down over the just the years
and years you know when you put it on
you pull it down so it has two holes in
here sweaty I use it only for working
out okay so it's not a way around
anywhere else I'm like that too it's not
a hoodie just for working out I have two
of them
my what my wife trying to one-up me
takes them and wears them my workout
thing and you know like you know let's
face it usually why it's not going to
wear the workout gear yeah but they're
so good it's like it's the most
comfortable hoodie in this whole
household the best boom I have one in
every color the heavy and the kilo oh
yeah yeah yeah uh yeah so all that stuff
made in America jeans boots hunt gear we
got the the line coming out for training
have you you haven't gone have you got
yours yet RTX the RTX line no you tell
me you don't have it yet because it's
been sent to one of our operators here
that's going to deliver it to you but
it's super good to go like I'm so stoked
this is one of the first things I asked
Pete for was like Hey man we need we
need to make like a workout clothing
this is what I do every day every day I
work out that's what I need every day
and so we got it
it's beautiful so RTX line coming out
all made in America 100 so you can
actually help your great great great
grandchildren live in Freedom
that's what you can do originusa.com go
get it it's true also Jack has a store
it's called Jocko store by the way so
yeah we're representing on this path
we're doing everything we're doing Jiu
Jitsu marathons is the case maybe I'm
not doing a marathon but nonetheless I
am representing on the path discipline
equals Freedom it's true so you have the
shirt Locker as part of the Jacko store
and my dad has been a long time
subscriber and he wears it's the only
shirts he wears and he's on a road trip
right now to Virginia Beach and he's two
times now on this road trip and stopped
people be like hey Jocko yeah
yeah yeah shirt Locker new shirt every
month different kind of design same path
same representation new design so that's
a good one
he's super proud of that that's a good
one he's super proud of that Echo
weights this entire podcast and then
like you pass it off and he's like now's
my time
you don't even know how right you are if
you can see him getting antsy at the end
like it's almost my turn if there's a
podcast where he doesn't say very much I
have to like brace for it because I know
he's gonna get in there and just start I
can't stop it you know and and so he's
gonna talk you know we just got to
contend with it yeah you started to
close this out and you could see him
like
face changed he started checking his
notes he was like you know yeah getting
everything right he's like I'm ready all
right get in the mental spot there I
like them observation that's so that's
so good observation is so right too I
see you over there straightening your
paper just getting ready to talk that's
a fair assessment yeah I shouldn't
contribute to this I really should have
your back on this Echo I'm sorry because
YouTube you two both experience a
workplace hostilities from me yeah we're
gonna do a podcast at some point just
sharing our our shared yeah we'll roll
it out
I know we're on some group text with
Echelon front and I don't know what you
did I forget but I wrote back like to
the group test text to you trust was
broken no I can tell you what I did what
did you do it was like a call and I was
traveling and I didn't set someone up as
the host on Zoom so no one could join
the zoom call and like I was like Hey
guys sorry next time I'll make sure that
I add some other people so you guys can
get on the zoom call and you're like
trust has been broken
oh yes I do and here's the thing I I see
where you're doing that's the thing I
see what you're doing like he'll go for
like the kind of low blow not like full
obvious little milk because it'd be two
hours
here's what he'll do to me he'll be like
hey you want to come to this thing or
should I call Carrie
I gotta go because they can't be like
yeah like basically count on someone
else you know it's like that kind of
stuff so I see what you're doing because
when I link up once a month and we just
have a support session that we just talk
through the abuse
there you go um nonetheless you are
correct I'm ready hey look if people
want to hear about the shirt Locker
who's gonna who's gonna tell them about
the shirt Locker yeah you speaking of
encouragement he doesn't need any more
encouragement to talk to him just FYI
for the our people are are not I'm not
appreciative uh subscribe to that
subscribe to the podcast
[Music]
um subscribe to Jocko underground we do
that podcast once a week generally
speaking we answer questions from you we
also talk about
Taco podcast adjacent topics they're
very focused on your moving through life
in an efficient manner so check that out
go to YouTube subscribe to our YouTube
channel doco podcast originusa
YouTube channel Jocko fuel has a YouTube
channel Echelon front has a YouTube
channel so we got all kinds of YouTube
channels
go subscribe to those things check them
out good good information psychological
warfare that's been around for a while
yeah get you through those moments of
weakness yeah well there you go uh
Flipside canvas Dakota Meyer books I
written a bunch of books you guys know
the gig get them if you if you haven't
gotten them yet especially kids books
look you might be you you might be uh uh
uh beyond help
you're not but you might think you are
but I tell you what the neighbor you
have with the two little Rugrats running
around getting crazy they could use
Uncle Jake it was Uncle Jake in the
lives of your children oh yes
we love Uncle Jake yeah the way of the
warrior kid is like the best thing you
can do for your kids because all the
things we teach about extreme ownership
are in this book and teaching it in a
way that kids can resonate with yeah and
for whatever reason again Jamie
Cochran's the Unicorn that obeyed her
her parents with like religious Zeal
most kids are not like that most kids
are going to be like oh I'm not gonna
listen to my dad what does my dad
possibly know you know my son when he
was 10 years old and we're doing Jiu
Jitsu and I said hey you need to move
your hips a little bit further over on
that arm lock and he's like no you don't
I'm like bro I've been doing Jiu Jitsu
twice as long as you've been alive and
now you're telling me I don't know how
to do an arm walk
but Uncle Jake the kids listen to Uncle
Jake all day and he's putting out some
good word let's face it so there you go
dude adults can read wave the warrior
kid and learn a bunch oh I know I love
those books yeah the the simple
straightforward methodology in way of
the warrior kid is definitely
it hits it lands as Echo Charles likes
to say so we get a bunch of books check
out those books Ashland front you heard
a little bit about it today Jamie
Cochran the Chief Operating Officer
there what do we do at Echelon front
what do we not do at Echelon front we
teach leadership we do a bunch of
different things we do high level
Consulting long-term programs with
clients and helping them put together
leadership development programs within
their company train the trainer
sustainment efforts we do one-off like
Keynotes and workshops and different
things that we can come in and help your
team understand and get a baseline
understanding these principles and then
obviously we have the events and
experiences that we do the musters the
field training exercises the battlefield
reviews the council now the women's
assembly and then we got a bunch of free
stuff and a bunch of stuff on the
academy so if you don't have time you
don't have maybe the money to come to
one of those events or to have us come
out and do training for your team you
can join the academy and there's a
plethora of free courses and then very
affordable courses you can take to get
really
dialed in on learning these principles
more effectively real quick what
here's a trivia question Echelon front
style what year was the first Echelon
front video created
oh I know but I don't know the year what
do you think well wait hold on hold on
hold on because early in the day I made
videos for Echelon in front okay all
right yeah I'll I'll pull out my uh it's
so bad if you saw it now you'd be like
what the heck I made a video from like
very early on it was like 2014. I went
with you guys to Denver and I took some
footage on my phone and I edited it in
like some it was not good back in the
day it felt fine but it's the starburst
website I designed and created I used
Wix and then you came along and you
stepped up our game with video and
website and you did a bunch of stuff
so I don't remember so instrumental I
don't remember whatever but I remember
the first time you made a video though
first video for Echelon front Taco yeah
what's your guess estimate I know you
remember the video yeah the video I
don't know what the time frame was but I
did a video I did a leadership training
I don't even know if actually I don't
know if it's not fun existed yeah it
might not have existed yet I did a
leadership training video for a company
and Echo filmed it and so you do win
anything it was before 2010. okay it was
actually me and Sarah by the way
remember what was she in here yes you
were doing she was doing like help was
it in this room in on the mats of
Justice what was the video the video was
for a teacher's assistant
I thought we filmed I didn't think we I
thought we filmed that in one of these
like around here you know on the mats in
there before Echelon front existed yeah
uh but I Revisited that maybe like a
year and a half ago and it it's all
Echelon front stuff yeah but literally
like to the language everything it was
it was before Echelon funny existed
because soon after that he was like hey
we need a logo that you know kind of
embodies This and like this and I was
like okay maybe I'll come up with
something he sends me a sketch made on
like Microsoft I still have that too by
the way yeah I'm gonna make a shirt with
that logo on it I'm only I'm gonna wear
it only mean k dog and wear it what do
you like this is the OG no make that
into a sherlocker shirt dude people
underestimate or don't realize how
artistic Drago is he's actually quite
artistic I get a lot of little drawings
when he's trying to explain something
and like you want to show me and I'm
like oh that's actually a really good
drawing and by the way it's not my
Echelon front logo well there's a
difference here because you're talking
about Microsoft draw or whatever stupid
ass program I was on trying to do this
thing but if you give me a pen I'll do
okay okay actually you're right about
that there's yeah okay okay actually
you're right you're right but here's the
deal so we get done we record this video
and it's like an hour long
it's a keynote and it's you know what
you pointed out earlier the principles
that your husband had written down when
he heard me talk about combat leadership
for the first time and you know it says
cover Move simple prioritizing yeah it's
the same stuff so I was doing this for
some uh company and the the audio was
off sync I look like a bad a bad dub and
I go hey I'm like hey Echo like the my
mouth is moving and no words are coming
out and then my mouth isn't moving and
words are coming out what it doesn't and
you know what he told me he was like no
no no it's fine he was trying to tell me
it was okay why were you doing that
because okay well this is literally what
happened so the thing was first off
that's my first video that I got paid
forever in my whole life how much did I
tell you I forget
50 bucks I was like no we like split it
or something like that okay they get
yeah you were if you were cooking it up
but um it was because the video's so
long and I didn't use any like tools or
or no visual aids nothing I just was
going by my own eyes and you know how
you get hypnotized
he was he was coming out we were going
back and forth for like more than an
hour saying us it is no it's not yes it
is no it's not yes it is no it's not for
to the point where he literally came to
my house to show me do you remember that
yeah
we found the one spot when he's like hey
and you just gotta know and he's doing
this and he's like look and he goes
let's begin the uh what that caused the
introduction of the Slate yeah the slave
so yes was correct he had to drive all
the way to my house your first video
ever was 2010. for money yes okay paid
gig but that's incredible didn't you you
did some you did some uh Victory
oh that was after yeah because those are
you know he's got outtakes of me like 15
16 17 years ago still talking still
talking still smack the funny thing is I
remember that conversation about the
timing being off
I was like hey I I was kind of
questioning myself but then I'm watching
it I'm like dude this is one of those
rare situations where the person you're
dealing with is actually just wrong like
they're just wrong it's true he's like
all hypnotized because you know like
you're like doing it for like an hour I
don't know had to drive to his house and
sit down and show him
that it was wrong
and I didn't know anything anyways we
got the mission done
accomplished so that's what we're doing
at Echelon front you can now uh get
trained by us and and what you just
mentioned so we have an online training
thing
extreme ownership.com this is the thing
you may not realize this if you're
walking around right now
or you know you know people that walk
around and they think they're really
good at fighting but they never trained
before right and you can go watch a
thousand videos of a blue belt and Jiu
Jitsu beating up a or tapping out a big
giant muscle head guy that doesn't know
how to fight
so there's some magic in Jiu Jitsu it's
the same thing with this stuff it
legitimately is like magic that you can
bring into your life right now you don't
even know that you don't know it right
now you think you'll I know how to
interact with my boss I know how to deal
with my subordinates I know how to do
that
just like that big muscle head thinks he
knows how to fight he doesn't know how
to fight and he ends up losing
and and looking around think it was a an
anomaly or thinking it was just because
that guy no your subordinate isn't
reacting the right way not because of
your support it's because of you your
boss isn't responding correctly to your
influence because of you
so if you want to learn these magic
tricks of leadership
go to extremotorship.com you will then
have power the cool thing is you take
Jiu Jitsu chances are you're not going
to get in a street fight but there's a
100 guarantee you're going to interact
with your supporter your peers and your
bosses that's 100 gonna happen so be
ready learn the magic then you'll be
good to go
extreme ownership.com go check it out
get a class
learn if you want to help service
members active and retired you want to
help their families Gold Star Family
check out Markley's mom mama Lee She's
Got an incredible charity organization
if you want to donate or want to get
involved go to America's Mighty Warriors
dot org
and also
Heroes and horses.org right now Micah
Fink what's the latest report Echo
Charles
uh it was a mountain lion two mountain
lions two mountain lions and then one of
them lost its head which now belongs to
Mike I think okay so Micah Fink is at
his present Mountain Camp with the head
of one mountain lion on a pike
that he killed his bare hands and he's
eating the other one at the current time
so
he's up there helping veterans find
themselves
in nature and find their path so there
you go if you want to connect with us on
the internet on the interwebs Jamie's on
the gram you're on the gram you're at
Jamie Lynn Cochran
you're on LinkedIn at Jamie Cochran
Echelon fronts on there by the way at
Echelon front you're not on Twitter are
you I'm not
how come I had to go on Twitter and you
didn't I remember your first tweet yeah
I know I just uh I don't have enough
time to manage social media accounts I
and no one's following me for stuff so
we we focus on Echelon front Echelon
front has Twitter and all those other
things so we focus efforts there do you
put out word on Echelon front social
media is that you at any point I used to
be now I don't yeah no the team does
that I get to like oversee a couple
things the the try this uh instead of
this try this that was me that was fun
I put those out I mean with help from
the team we got a lot of uh responses
from the team so we put those out every
Monday but the team does it all
do you remember my first tweet I did
what did I write my first tweet I wrote
my first tweet no no what happened no we
you early on were like hey we don't need
social media early on you were like hey
you know I knew what you were doing
before the book came out you were not
super excited about this idea of going
on social media and I ended up getting
with some support from Jenna and Leif to
get all your guys's stuff and just keep
it on the back burner in case we
somebody needed it and then you did the
Tim Ferriss podcast and you called me
and you're like hey Tim's twittering
about me or like the way you described
it I was like that's not accurate but uh
and like I need to use it and so we had
these accounts set up and we hadn't done
anything with them and so I was like all
right I showed you how to log in and
we're on the phone I remember being like
no no you have to use the the hashtag
it's the number sign and I'm like
walking you through it like line by line
and you tweet it and then I call you
back I'm like hey it was wrong you
tagged the wrong person and you're like
okay hold on so you delete it and you
retweet it and then I went to bed and I
woke up up the next day and you had like
200 followers and you had responded to a
bunch and I never once again helped you
with social media you just had it locked
in it was like overnight you figured it
out but that first tweet yeah I remember
making some kind of mistake and you're
like no yeah well because you sent it
and then I was looking and I was like he
tagged the wrong person I tagged like
Timothy H for Ross
in Kentucky yeah but I only helped you
once and then you had it and nobody
touches your social I think there's
that's a surprise for a lot of people is
that you don't have a team of people
running your social media you post and
you maintain
Yeah Tim Ferriss told me he goes you got
to do this Twitter thing and I was like
I don't really you know know how to do
that stuff he goes don't just just get
it and then I'll show you how to do it
he never showed me anything Tim if
you're listening to this but he did get
he told me like how
effective it was for interacting with
people and it really is you know it's it
is kind of overwhelming now because
there's a lot of you know there's a lot
of people that will reach out but it is
awesome to be able to just talk to
somebody in Kentucky or in Bangladesh or
in Australia boom there they are you can
talk to them it's pretty amazing so
we're on there Jamie's on Instagram if
you want to follow Jamie on Instagram
she's also with Echelon front uh so
that's where we're at Echo and I are
also on there
echo's at Echo Charles
I'm at Jocko willink just just please
just watch out for the algorithm
because it'll get you
anything else watch out for those fake
accounts too oh yeah those Bots will get
you the Bots are crazy I can't believe
there's like fake Jocko accounts that
are like Jocko with like no seat like
they exist yeah that's why you got the
verification yeah
but I don't have verification on Twitter
anymore somebody told me that's your
thing where's your blue check mark and
so I gotta figure that one out it seemed
like I just saw something the other day
Elon tweeted that you can have two hour
videos now oh damn if you're on so
that's that actually might move me in
the direction of paying the money
because right now the limits are like
two minutes or something and sometimes
my videos be longer than that so then I
have to link you over but I don't do
this
a pain so that's it anything else Echo
Charles
negative thanks Jamie for coming down
thank you for having me Jamie anything
else from you no appreciate the
opportunity right on awesome uh thanks
once again thanks for joining us um
it's awesome we really appreciate it I
appreciate you you and I would say you
don't know how much appreci I appreciate
you but I actually think you know how
much I appreciate you because my life
depends on you so and I know you know
that so thank you for everything you do
for us and
um also thanks for the military
personnel out there tonight and I want
to say especially thanks to all the
military spouses that are out there who
take care of the home front so that your
military Warrior can take care of us
thank you you spouses you families you
kids
you moms and dads of those service
members thanks for your service and
sacrifice tonight and the same thing
goes to our police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics EMTs dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
Secret Service all First Responders
thanks to you also and again thanks to
your spouses
thanks to your spouse's thanks to your
kids who take care of your families so
that you
can take care of us and to everyone else
out there from a leadership perspective
let's remember
the underlying core
of Colonel David hackworth's attitude as
a leader he never did things for
personal gain
he always did things for the unit
and for the soldiers
for the soldiers
that's your team you put the team first
that is universal in leadership and the
same way it worked for hackworth in
Korea the same way it worked for
hackworth in Vietnam
the same way
who works for Jamie
taking care of her team putting the unit
and putting her people first
and that is leadership
leadership on the battlefield leadership
and business leadership with your family
leadership in your life put the team
first
that
is how you lead
then until next time this is Jamie and
Echo and Jocko
out